e
good
morning this is a uh public hearing of
Science Tech and energy committee I am
Vice chair Doug Thomas filling in for
chairman Vose while he attends another
commitment he should be here before
10:00 so before we start our proceeding
on the first bill I will invite um
representative laraj to please uh lead
allegiance to the flag the United States
of America to the stands one nation God
indivisible liberty and justice for all
thank
you okay we have a a thin contingent
here this morning we have several people
that are out for illness and some have a
temporary commitment so with that being
said uh I am opening up the meeting for
HB
537 later on this morning we will hear
uh testimony for bills HP 539 HP 680 in
the afternoon uh we'll cover HP 5 654 FN
HB 541 and
sb4 so for HB 537 I will invite
representative Alison knob to come up
and introduce the bill representative
yours thank you for having me Mr chair
and members of the committee my name is
Alison NAB I'm uh represent Rockingham
12 in strata and um as some of you know
I am introducing this bill on behalf of
Representative Manos so um this is
partly her statement on behalf of HB
537 um this bill and the two bills that
follow it cover the same situation which
is shared electric meters for well and
septic pumps in residential condominiums
in particular some residential units in
addition to having their own individual
electric meters also share a met meter
with an enjoining neighbor these shared
meters are strict for well and septic
pump usage and so the purpose of these
bills is to um ensure that these meters
are build at the residential rate
instead of the commercial rate which is
currently the
situation um and the commercial rate is
higher so the effort is that they are
residential for residential purposes the
water and septic and that this would
return them to being build as
residential at the residential
rate um this was brought on behalf of
several condo owners in our town that
are concerned about this and in
particular the Vineyards which you will
hear a resident from The Vineyards
shortly talk about this bill uh the
homeowners association cannot on the
advice of council change the charge this
expense back to the paired units so the
homeowners association is then forced to
charge this expense back to all unit
owners this is an overcharge of
commercial rates for residential units
but also a cost shift from shared meters
to all units as opposed to just the ones
impacted um it's come to the attention
of the Prime sponsor that these three
bills actually could really cover the
same situation and could potentially be
comined into one bill and so um It's Our
intention to work with this committee or
anyone on this committee to combine them
into one bill that would cleanly solve
this problem and
um I think with that uh I would be
willing to take any questions or I will
defer questions to other speakers
following
me thank
you I have one quick question I know
you're not the prime sponsor but uh at
the risk of asking uh I I do see that
down on line 16 uh they added the RSA
378 uh colon 6-a do you have any idea
what that says because I did a quick
search and couldn't find it this
morning or perhaps the next speaker
problem representative bernardy has a
question thank you chair
um is it your understanding that that
all shared meters are always build at
the commercial rate as opposed to
residential or is this unique to uh this
kind of a
property um it's my understanding that
they are and there was a bill the last
term that would have addressed this
issue but there were concerns about the
extent to which it would apply to a
shared space pool other facilities that
may be would not be the same as an
individual homeowner would have so this
is to say why would a condo association
be charged at a commercial rate for
septic and water which is something
every homeowner needs a pool is a
different situation a shared you know
activity space is a different situation
so this bill tightens up what the um in
iteration last term was to only apply to
septic and water is my understanding
thank you and sorry do you mind um one
other concern was this use of the term
commercial because um I think commercial
in this in this situation applies to
anything that's not an individual home
but this is for residential condos it's
not meant to apply to any commercial
condos that are actually condos that
have um that have uh True commercial
them see no further questions thank you
representative I will call next on Mr
Richard sweat
is this on y okay thank you yeah my name
is uh Richard SWAT I live at 26 Vineyard
Drive stratum New Hampshire uh good
morning chairman well gu boss I guess he
isn't here but members of the Science
Tech and energy committee and thank you
for the opportunity to testify before
this committee to introduce my myself
I'm a 17-year resident of The Vineyards
at stratum Condominium Association it's
an age 55 and older community
Association and we're subject to the
354-5774
years of service as a condominium
president and I volunteer on many
condominium committees that support the
infrastructure of the Condominium
Association I'm also chairman of the
condominium Leadership Council a member
of Ci's legislative action committee I
have a 33e experience in the financial
services business and I'm a US Navy
veteran
so I agree with representative nab's
idea to present one bill addressing the
issues raised in hp37 HB 39 and hb680
it's a good idea and I would support
that proposal I also agree with attorney
daario's email to the committee stating
that the opinion that Condominiums are
and I quote inherently commercial is a
conclusion that is and I quote again
inherently inaccurate and I will address
HB
537 the department of Energy's letter
dat of January 16 202 for H uh objected
to hp430 and the letter made the
following statement because condominium
associations are by Nature commercial
entities service provided to common
areas and common facilities are treated
as and charged as nonresidential and
build at the Tariff rates which would be
schedual G commercial uh that's
statement that condominium associations
by n nature commercial entities is not
correct HB 537
amends RSA
356b 16 RSA 378 6A and RSA
3622 to Define residential condom units
as not operating commercial or business
Enterprise to operate it in lemon common
areas as residential
Condominiums the existence of
residential Condominiums is further
evident
by the following documents as required
by RSA 356 B16 the Condominium Act
condom contents of Declaration which
requires a statement of purpose for
which the condominium in each of the
units are intended and restricted to use
and they that would be defined as
residential condominiums in the
Declaration if the association is
registered as a nonprofit corporation
with the new New Hampshire Secretary of
State under r sa
2922 and the principal purpose is to
promote the welfare of the residents the
association is a residential condominium
RSA 356 b51 b51 requires that
residential condominiums that have more
than 10 units which we are must be
registed with the Consumer Protection
Bureau so there is plenty of evidence
that con residential Condominiums
exists condominium associate ations not
permitting commercial or business
enterprises should be charged the same
electric rates as condominium
residential units for domestic septic
and well pumped electric usage HP 537
limits electric rates to domestic
household septic and well electric usage
this limitation addresses the department
of Energy's concern that common area
facility such as clubhous is swimming
pools tennis courts racket balls picket
balls all those types of facilities was
way too broad so it has been narrowed to
septic and pump electric usage the
vineyard's board of directors and the
condominium Leadership Council support
the passage of HB
537 thank
you thank you Mr s do I see any
questions
from our members representative
minardi thank you Mr chair uh you cite
attorney the Dario I I don't know what
what his relevancy to this is is I tell
you he is the uh lead attorney for the
New Hampshire legislative action
committee and I believe he sent an email
to all the members of this committee uh
supporting this bill and I have a copy
of of the email if you would like to see
it if he did it's fine I'm behind in my
emails that's quite all right I am too
there's no question about it we get way
welcome I have one quick question
because I'm not as well versed in this
subject as as you are
uh you're from stratum I am have you
canvased the rest of the state with
other condo associations to see if uh if
they're running the same type of um
feeling you know that's a very
interesting question I asked the
consumer Bureau of of uh protection as
they're required to keep a list of all
residential Condominiums are supposed to
file with them so I asked them to send
me a list and they said they do not have
such a list so the answer is no I have
not
canvas uh the other associations because
I wouldn't know how to recognize them if
if the consumer Bureau of protection had
that represent
question thank you thank you um I just
was wondering do most
condominium unit um associations don't
they have an
office and that would be commercial
wouldn't it how would they differentiate
between the
office commercial part and the
residential Parts well in our particular
Condominium Association we do not have
an office we have a management company
great North management company and that
company serves as the manager of our
Condominium Association and if people
have complaints they would go to the
management
company yes sir G
Swanson thank you uh Vice chair Thomas
and thank you for being here uh relative
to the uh uh uh condo or uh suddenly
forgetting the name of the The Entity
that you just me mentioned is that a
commercial
entity I I'm sorry I I I I I I didn't
hear the question somebody could repeat
it for me I'd appreciate it you
mentioned being uh the the condos are
owned by a corporation
right or is that an associate
managed by an uh a Condominium
Association is formed by
356b we can remain incorporated or
unincorporated some Condominiums
associations decide to become
Incorporated they become Incorporated
under RSA
2922 to they get registered with the New
Hampshire Secretary of State in their
statement of purpose they say they're
for the welfare or the benefits of the
condominium so some some can be
Corporation but they are nonprofit
corporations and I did speak to an
attorney at the consumer Bureau of
protection who basically said under that
statute you can be a residential
condominium okay so those incorporations
are nonprofit yes okay thank you thank
you
Mr yes I I'll have a question to for my
understanding to clarify what I think I
just heard was that it depends on how
condo associations are have labeled
themselves with the Secretary of State
might determine whether they're
considered residential or commercial is
was that what you were
saying um that I would say this that you
go back to the condominium declaration
and the and the Declaration of intent in
the condomini Declaration would say
whether you're commercial or whether you
are residential now as I said
Condominiums can remain unin inated
under 356b the Condominium Act or they
can become Incorporated under
2922 uh many attorneys recommend that
condominium associations especially
residential condominium associations do
not become Incorporated they should
remain under 356b as the Condominium Act
so uh really I would say the basic
document that would decide whether a
condominium is residential or commercial
is a condominium declaration
thank
you see no other questions uh thank you
Mr s excellent testimony thank you and
I'll call on the last pink card I have
here uh Megan Stone from the Department
of
morning thank you good morning Mr chair
and members of the committee I'm Megan
Stone legislative liaison with the
Department of energy the department is
neutral on House Bill 537 but we do have
concerns with the bill as introduced um
section one of the bill requires
declarations for every condominium to
include a description or delineation of
The Limited common areas if any showing
or designating the unit or units to
which each is assigned and whether any
commercial or business enterprises are
permitted section two of the bill
requires that condominium associations
do not permit uh commercial or business
enterprises shall be charged the same
electric rate as condominium residential
units for domestic septic and well pump
electric usage in section three as our
understanding of the bill requires that
section two also be applied to um R
rural uh electric cooperatives for which
a certificate of deregulation is on file
with the Public Utilities
Commission condominium associations may
have common areas or joint used
facilities served by an electric meter
or meters electric service to common
areas or common facilities provides
benefit beyond that provided to an
individual home or residence the use of
electricity in those common areas or
facilities is not residential in nature
and that service provided is
appropriately classified as
non-residential New Hampshire's Electric
utilities classify Service as commercial
or residential with different rate
options available within each broad rate
class and House Bill 537 would permit
conduit associations across the state to
delineate their limited common areas and
determine whether any commercial or
business Enterprises are permitted in
those areas an electric utility would be
required to provide service under its
residential rates to any common areas
that do not have any business or
commercial Enterprises the part
department believes this bill is
introduced has several unintended
consequences the bill permits condo
associations which are commercial ENT
entities uh which I can address
afterwards to determine whether business
or commercial Enterprises take place in
common areas of their property as a
result condo associations rather than
the electric utility would have the
authority to determine the rate
I'm sorry there should be no
interruption well during
testimony wait till after testimony
please well but my comment is could you
please speak just a tiny bit slower
that's all yes a question to the chair
and I would agree a little slower sorry
closer to the microphone please ask next
time please thank
you as a result condo associations
rather than the electric utility would
have have the authority to determine the
rate classification residential or
non-residential under which it would pay
for utility Service as a result of that
shift and who determines the appropriate
utility rate there is a potential for
the under recovery of costs and shifting
of costs between residential to
non-residential
customers 53 House Bill 537 inappropri
inappropriately shifts the determination
of an appropriate rate from the utility
to the customer allowing Hondo
Association to choose what rate it wants
to take services
under um and I think there there was a
question before as to why uh as to condo
associations being commercial rather
than residential um condo owned but if
you have shared residential space that's
under the homeowners
association um that that is a that is
nonr a homeowners association is
non-residential in terms of uh Electric
utilities and therefore it would be a
non-residential commercial rate um and
the department believes that there is uh
a non-legislative solution to this issue
simply uh it is our understanding simply
changing the name of the account holder
from a condo association or a homeowners
association um or property management
company to a resident would change the
rate from a commercial one to a
residential
run and I'm happy to take questions um I
am not well versed in condo law so I can
do my best but uh the
uh I'm happy to take questions where can
there must be a question I'm sure uh
representative Reynolds well thank you
um Mr Vice chair and I'm I'm sorry I
can't really think of a way to phrase
this as a as a question but I'm glad you
just admitted that you're not an expert
in condo law because I believe that your
assertion during your
testimony that condo associations are
commercial entities
uh is
incorrect
um the management
companies that condo associations might
hire to manage the Affairs of the condom
andum
Association are probably commercial
entities that I don't I think that these
those concepts are being conflated
here
condominium is a group of residences for
everyone's Ed ific I mean Condominium
Association a condominium is a legal
form of real estate ownership and
operation there are residential condos
where people live is there a question
there no I'm just we if we're going to
have a reason question and discussion we
we got to have this have the the facts
correct perhap perhaps perhaps I can
help perhap I I believe what the
representative was attempting to ask is
please explain why you feel that a condo
association would be residential uh
would be commercial versus residential
so it is just it's my understanding that
if you have a homeowners association
that is collecting dues and taking care
of parts of a condo association with
shared spaces fountains um even uh I
pump sheds or something like that where
you're serving multiple people and
they're taking in dues and they are
Incorporated whether they're a 501c3 or
they are they're in a a corporation um
that that is a that just qualifies them
representative Thomas your question
thank you um yes um I will you be
providing written testimony about this
and in the future can you please make
sure because um just so that we
understand what you're saying thank you
yes I'm sorry I want I can get a little
ahead of myself sometimes so I'm sorry I
went too
fast uh one representative Swanson your
question uh thank you Mr Vice chair and
thank you for your testimony uh real
just to
recap you just indicated that there is
an alternative vehicle for ensuring that
one
can uh uh condos can uh get the
residential rate and that's just through
the process of making sure that they've
filed as non-commercial use and that
takes care of it is that that is our
understanding
yes the Department's understanding
yes okay I'll take I'll I'll take this
time for the final question SL comment
is that I am a little bit bit um
perplexed as to uh why we don't have a
utility represented here today that
might have answered some of those
questions is this um do you believe that
this is something that the utilities
could have answered or is this fall
directly under the uh
doe they they could have more
information as but I I can't speak to
them I not
sure okay okay representative Tom's last
question sure thank you um your
suggestion about billing to individual
units um is a little off base because um
this this bill is about shared meters so
can you speak to that please um so I
think it just comes down to uh I think
in section one where uh it's talking
about I'm just just trying to find where
I'm sorry could
you I'm just trying to uh figure out
was do you need some help could could
you just elaborate a bit um so you
you're testifying that um your
suggestion about billing to individual
units um with regard to this bill but
the bill is about the shared meters not
individual
units you can get back yes I'll get back
to you thank
you okay see any other questions thank
you very much I do not see any other uh
cards here for speakers so I will
declare
this point of order Vice
chair I also had trouble in
comprehending with the speed of of the
last presenter as did representative
Thomas what would be the correct way
to interrupt
the I would say in a in a case like that
you would raise your hand and say
question for the chair and then I would
recognize you and then you would ask the
chair to uh please advise the uh
testifier to speak slowly more clearly
microphone thank
you okay with that being said I declare
public uh testimony for HP 537
closed and since we have about 2 minutes
of space here uh it'll be 2 minutes
before we open testimony on the next
reprieve yeah what's unclear to me is is
are the reasons for this billing built
into these statutes the rsas or not
that's what I don't understand the
are
I was was entertained watching the
videos last night entertained by what I
okay I declare the public hearing open
for HB
539 and I have a representative Al now
to please come up again and introduce
introduce the bill
welcome
you thank you Mr chair my name is Alison
NAB representing Rockingham 12 stratum
in New Hampshire thank you for having me
in front of the committee again today um
as I mentioned 539 is quite similar to
537 the bill that we just spoke about um
it just introduces it in a different
place in Statue so it would be Our
intention to amend these bills to
combine them into one but if you don't
mind uh Mr chair me address seen a
couple of the concerns that have come up
that would impact both these bills I'd
like to do that or I'm sorry could you
repeat that um if you don't mind if I
speak in general to some of the concerns
that have come up about this legislation
it's it's your time sure well I just I
want to be in order um so one of the
pieces that I would like to mention is
that it has been unitel who is the
utility impacting the condo association
in our town it has been their position
that a shared meter must be um build at
a commercial rate and they've been
unwilling to address this issue or
change it in any way which is why we
have arrived at attempting a legislative
solution um it's been suggested that
this could be done in a non-legislative
way and that is true but I would just
ask you to imagine a situation in which
a single homeowner becomes responsible
for a shared um a shared meter and then
has to Bill out the other people that
share that meter with him it's it's
complicated and not and and I think
problematic it would be non-legislative
but I don't think it's a very clean
solution and I think it's rape with
problems problems to ask a single
homeowner to then be the billing agent
for a shared meter and um you had asked
a question earlier about 378 and 378
just adds the Electric Co-op to the list
of utilities impacted so that is true
for all three pieces of legislation that
378 has been added so um again and and
to address the I mentioned this earlier
but you know just as a reminder this
does impact septic and well that is an
effort to make this very tailored to
something that is considered residential
if you are a resident of a home or a
condo you have a right to septic and
well that's not a pool it's not a shared
event space it's not an office it is a
it's a component of being a resident and
so um this is an attempt to get those
those charges addressed at a residential
rate instead of a commercial
rate and with that I will try and answer
questions I have one question out of oh
sorry representative
ploi thank you Vice
chair since you brought you you were
using your time I'm looking
at
property I owned shared laundry
facilties
commercial these Condominiums because of
the Condominium Act uh RSA they're
residential but they want to share like
the laundry room
and we as a condo owners they all own
it's no commercial Venture they're just
trying to split the expense evenly for
Mutual
use and I'm having trouble why utilities
want to call that a commercial it's not
open to the public it's just that
and I'm just looking at as a fair share
and it needs a meter so they can a lot
can you comment on my or could you reply
to my comment make sense out of it thank
you well it sounds like you're speaking
to the concern that we have right and
why this bill was introduced yes I and
so maybe I'm not understanding your
question rip couldn't
explain I'm sorry to I was using that
for one example because it a Wells and
the
septic why isn't it all I know you're
trying to whittle out those
two and I can't understand why it can't
be all of those shared expenses
but um sure and I'll I'll take a stab at
it um this bill a similar version of
this bill was introduced to the um
Commerce Committee last term and they
had some questions about if you had you
know a shared space that maybe someone
wanted to have a party in or a pool and
it sort of got murky as to whether that
was truly residential or those spaces
could be
considered what if someone charged for
them what if they had some commercial
component I think is that is that sort
of what you're getting out so I think
that's why it was tightened to just say
you know the water that you're getting
out of your tap and the septic that
you're using in your condo um that's
what would be impacted here and not a
shared space like a laundry room or like
a vent space or like a
pool is is there a followup question no
I I believe my question has been
this representative
RS thank you Vice chair I promise it's a
question uh representative NAB do you
believe that the department of energy is
mistaken in their
a blanket classification of all
residential condominium associations in
entities um I I'm not going to call them
mistaken but I think it's a really
problematic term because you get into
having a couple of different ideas of
what is commercial I don't think
something should be Comm considered
commercial just because it's shared so
you know if three condos are sharing one
meeting
I don't think that should make it
inherently commercial um and I think
most of us when we think of the term
commercial especially given that there
are condos that are truly commercial
that have real businesses in them um
you're creating this really murky setup
when you're using that term so um than
so I do disagree with their assertion I
guess but I think they're basing it on
something that maybe exists in other
places besides the department of energy
this idea that a condo association is a
commercial entity
thank you okay you see no further
questions thank you again for your
testimony I appreciate it and again I
will call on Mr Richard sweat again from
the New Hampshire
LA to give his testimony on
well once again thank you for having me
to testify on Bill one 539 you know who
I am so we'll skip that uh HB 539 amends
RSA 371a so that residential electric
rates for domestic consumption shall
apply to well and septic systems of
individual units within a condominium
Association which does not permit
commercial or business
enterprises so back again we're trying
back to the definition of a residential
condominium so I will say your electric
bill has two sections one section is the
supplier's kilowatt charge for delivery
and the other and that kilowatt charge
is assigned by the Pu tariff it's either
a SCH G which is commercial or a
Schedule D which is domestic now the
electric supplier supplying electric
energy competes for customers in the
marketplace by offering competitive
pricing the department of energy
provides a listing of 19 companies who
will supply electric energy to
residential customers stratum Community
power supplies electric electricity to
customers at kilow hour fixed rat
averaging 21% less than kilowatt hours
fix rates offered by Unitil for the
period February 2024 to January
2025 this is a competitive Marketplace
the other portion of the bill is the
delivery of electric energy to a Regal
customer is not a competitive
Marketplace the state of New Hampshire
has granted electric utility franchises
to area franchise areas to companies
such as Liberty unitel NH EC and
eversource the electric utility granted
granted the franchise makes a decision
on which tariff schedule is assigned to
an electric meter Schedule D domestic or
schedule G commercial the residential
customer has no choice in deciding which
tariff schedule is assigned to an
electric meter
Schedule D domestic delivery service is
quote available under this schedule for
all domestic purposes unquote
residential condominium units consuming
poble water and discharging waste water
into septic systems is necessary for
domestic use and without poble water and
a septic system to process Wastewater
the units would not be habitable the
electric meters providing electricity to
pumps supplying pable water and pumping
Wastewater to leech Fields should be
assigned the schedule D tariff HP 539
would require the franchise protected
electri Electric utilities to assign the
correct tariff schedule for domestic use
by residential units the board of
directors of The Vineyards and the
condem Leadership Council support the
539 thank you questions representative
Thomas thank you um could you please
repeat the association that supports
this you mentioned it at the very
end of your testimony I'm not I uh with
your mask on it's for hard for me to
hear these Sor uh could you please
repeat the association that supports
this you mentioned it at the very end oh
yeah okay it's in my it's in the
testimony I gave so you'll have a copy
there the the uh Vineyard the well the
condominium Leadership Council has eight
condominium associations associated with
it that support this bill The Vineyards
of stratom Condominium Association is in
the condomini Leadership Council and
they support the bill the New Hampshire
legislative action committee also
supports the bill those are the those
are the organization support supporting
this bill oh thank you very
much representative R you got a question
yes thank you Mr Vice chair
um in your view is the problem is the
Crux of the problem that this bill
addresses the fact that it appears to be
the utilities who have
the power the discretion to assign the
rate class to condominium
associations the answer and no one else
the answer to that is yes back in 2021
October of 2021 we started our
conversation with unitel we wrote a
registered letter to I forgotten the
name of the gentleman he was a vice
president of the of of the of the
organization he assigned it to another
vice president of the organization who
assigned it to the rate manager of the
organization and we dealt with uh unel
for a period of time and that was
unsuccessful then we went and we dealt
with the Department of energy we spoke
with Amanda Nunan and I forgotten the
other gentleman's name and uh we did not
get any resolution so now we were we
were it was recommended that we look for
a legislative resolution of this problem
and so we are here today for that
you okay I have one final question uh
and please understand I don't I've never
lived in a condo I'm not familiar with
condo you don't know what you're missing
I know someday I may have to I don't
know so is is this bill 539 saying
that the utility is is um charging
commercial rates to well pumps and
septic systems to uh that are shared by
condoman and that they ought to be uh
charging residential rates that's
exactly right a matter of fact one of
the reasons why this bill is limited
limited to residential Condominiums and
limited to septic systems and well pumps
is because a year
ago the department of energy again
objected to that bill because it was too
broad they thought that it it should be
it was too broad it would include as I
said before clubhouses which could could
should be running out for a profit which
would be commercial it could include
swimming pools that might be running out
for swim meets so it was too broad so
this bill was designed to to address
that objection and make it specifically
for residential condominiums for the
specific purpose of making making those
units
habitable thank you and my followup uh
clarification question would be
there this going to sound very obvious
uh so therefore if there were cheaper
rates assigned to the septic and and
well systems those rates would be
savings would be equally distributed
amongst all of the condo owners that
would be true that would that would be
true
yes okay well thank you for indulging my
ignorance
condos thank you that's all right we're
educate I have a question from
representative
Harrington thank you and thank you
foring my question I'm just uh looking
at line 14 of the bill it seems to be
the main thrust of it here it says
residential electric rat for domestic
consumption shall apply to well pump and
septic systems for individual units
within the condo so basically what
you're saying here is you're going to be
charging somebody in a condo the same
way the same way like I paid at my house
I have a well and a septic system and I
get charged residential rat this would
be applying that same standard to
Condominiums that's true and followup
and it's not being done consistently now
or is it not being done at all or well
right now we're being charged a
scheduled G rate which is a commercial
rate and the design of 537 539 and 680
is to correct that imbalance and get
assign the scheduled drate which you are
which you pay as a
residential consumer of electricity okay
follow up
again I can wait go ahead goad M Thomas
um thank you um can you give me an idea
can you please give me an idea of the
financial impact to go from schedule G
to schedule D how much money are we
talking about I would say say this it
would only affect the delivery side of
your utility bill and I would say on the
delivery side of your utility bill it
meter I'm sorry is that per month uh
followup yes that would be uh on a
I just it's really a quick question one
I'll one quick followup represent
Harrington thank you uh so I'm assuming
then that for the rest of your electric
usage your lights your television your
refrigerator you're all getting charg
the residential and you have two
separate medas for this that' be true
yes for the for the rest of the domestic
use whatever you just as you said it's
all Schedule D okay thank you okay no
further questions thank you for your
testimony again and I will ask Mr Regan
Stone from the Department of energy to
come up and invite any
other utility that might be here that
may want to speak to fill out a pink
card if they so Desire Miss
Stone morning thank you Mr chair and
members of the committee Megan Stone
legislatively is on with the Department
of energy um I will not read go through
my entire testimony from the last bill
again but I would just like to add
electric service for an individual well
pump or pumps for individual electric uh
septics systems typically run through
the residential meter on a home or a
condo when a well or septic system
provides water and septic to multiple
homeowners the electric service to those
systems benefit multiple customers and
regardless of the profit or nonprofit
status of the organization to whom the
service is build the service is
appropriately classified as commercial
whether for-profit or nonprofit those
organizations are required to register
as a business with the Secretary of
State hopefully that can provide a
little bit more clarification to what I
was talking about earlier thank
you thank you questions representative
Harrington thank you thank you foring a
question I think this is sort of the key
Point here on this bill what you're
saying is that if if I'm in a
condominium and I have I guess would be
a single electric meter that covers not
only my refrigerator and you know light
bulbs and so forth but also covers my my
we
and my septic I'm charged 100% the
residential rate but if in the
condominium there's let's say eight
units and all eight have a mutual um
well pump and a mutual septic system
which is charged to basically a third
entity and then distribute it to the
condominium that that's charged the
commercial rate is that correct yes all
questions seeing none thank you thank
you Miss
Stone next up we'd ask Michael Lata of
eversource to give us his perspective on
this
morning good morning uh Michael Lata
eversource energy uh really just here to
answer questions that the committee may
have uh I recognize that this appears to
be a specific situation uh with a
different util
uh however if I can answer questions
I'll do my best I might have to uh come
back and provide answers after the fact
representative Bernardi has a question
thank you Mr chair so you heard the
discussion of uh representative
Harrington uh and the answer was that
a shared septic and water meter for
multiple residential units is now being
considered commercial is that a
statutory requirement or is that a
utility making that
decision uh I'm
gonna ultimately the determination um
would be based upon our tariff which is
basically the kind of conditions which
we provide service to customers those
tariffs are approved by the Public
Utilities Commission and and in essence
carry uh similar of the force of law I I
don't know the answer of whether that
there is a
statutory requirement to to do that
treatment or whether it is in each
utilities
tariff I I think the as my understanding
of the issue comes
to the use of the electricity versus The
Entity
that the account is in so for
eversource if the account is in and the
meter is in the name of a commercial
Enterprise they are charged the
commercial rates regardless of whether
the use is to support in this case a
multifam condominium or an apartment
building if it isn't a commercial entity
they pay commercial rates if it is in
the name of a residential
customer they pay residential rates the
utility is somewhat blind to what goes
on behind the meter if it's being used
for you know for for water for shared
lighting for whatever it might be at the
condominium so for us um it is there's
Clarity in saying you know you're a a
commercial Enterprise you're registered
with the Secretary of State New
Hampshire therefore you pay commercial
rates
versus you know you're a commercial
customer but you're telling us and we
would have to believe you that this is
being used for a different purpose which
I believe for a residential purpose
which I believe is the intent of the
bill follow up follow
up so uh you may not have been here for
uh this comment from the Department of
energy but uh the suggestion was then if
that meter was put in the name of the
residents as opposed to the uh Condo
Association that would change its
building schedule from G to D such so in
this case the 10 residents that live at
that Condo
Association would all put their common
names on that water and sewer meter and
that would make this issue go away so I
I the only caveat I have to that is the
the the 10 names I I don't know from a
billing standpoint if it would have to
be in one individual I mean obviously
just I'll speak for myself my my wife
and I are both on on our electric
account I don't know how many people we
could could have on that account uh
listed but I I again I can take that
back and ask but to answer your sort of
the underlying philosophical
question if it is right now in the name
of a commercial Enterprise a condo
association and it is changed to a
residential customer or
customers yes that they would be charged
the residential rate thank you Vice
chair Thomas has a question uh thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question uh uh hopping on the previous
question from the previous
representative I can ask you would would
it be
a billing
conundrum if you were to put multiple
residential names onto one bill given
the fact that every single different
resident would likely have a different
address correct and so you know it would
the bill would go to one address if you
have multiple names I mean at that point
I don't
know how the association or or how that
group of customers would go about paying
the bill I mean that would be not
something that we would have insight
into um I I I understand the the
question I just it's would be you know
we send a bill to one address usually it
has one or or two names on it I I don't
know I I don't believe we could send it
to multiple addresses different names
you know there would be I think issues
with
that representative uh Harrington has a
question thank you U thank you for my
question I'm not sure if you can answer
this but I'm going to just throw it out
for the point of discussion so let's
just say for example the condo
association had an agreement that said
the president of the condo association
is going to be the name on this common
meter and it'll be that person's name
and that person's address and then the
rules of the condo association will
determine
how that money gets collected from
everybody and sent into the utility
would that then make it a residential
meter if the president of the condo
association was a residential customer
meaning that the the the account was not
uh a commercial account so he didn't
start his address if it was just Fred
Jones his address and he wants to you
know pass a hat around every month uh
again that would not be something
something that we would have insight to
we would only see this is a residential
customer therefore he should be charged
or she charge residential rates thank
you representative Swanson has a
question thank you Mr chair uh thank you
Mr Lata for being here uh you're
speaking on behalf of eversource would
unel have you think they would have the
same interpretation as far as when the
application is made that uh as far as
they would be determined to be
residental or commercial I I can only
speak on behalf of eversource I can't uh
vouch for any other or or state any
other utilities position on how they
apologize okay seeing no other questions
Bernardi thank you Mr chair um so the
default position is if the name is a
associate or an entity it's going to get
a commercial rate is there an
opportunity within your Billing System
to ask one question further Downstream
is this
Association engaged in commercial
activity versus residential activity
could you flag the system that way and
then make this discrimination so I I I
think that would be
problematic
um you know I I think I think if this
bill were to
pass uh we would essentially code that
customer as
residential um and you know that's
ultimately a determination of of this
body if you want to do that to allow a
commercial
Enterprise to access residential rates
and again we don't you know we're sort
of taking it on Blind Faith that that is
in fact what's happening
different commercial you know we would
have no way of knowing that a different
commercial
Enterprise uh would say yet you know me
too I'm using this for just you know
residential purposes we have no way to
audit that check that I mean it it would
it would be beyond our capabilities and
you representative Matson has a question
thank you chair um I I was wondering how
difficult it would be for a commercial
entity to transfer over to residential
is that something that the association
can do
easily I I think it would be as simple
as uh just transferring the account into
an individual's name but I I can check
but I I don't think that that would be a
challenge representative PL uh thank you
chair um thank you Mr Lata I I missed in
my notes did everus have a position on
you okay seeing no further questions I
want to thank you Mr Lata for giving us
your perspective on this legislation I
have no more pink cards on this
bill would anybody else like to say
anything before I close this public
hearing okay this public hearing is
closed we'll now move on to House Bill
68- FN I will open a public hearing on
that and ask representative Allison NAB
to introduce this legislation to
so the legislative uh budget office has
stated that this bill has no fiscal
impact on the state so the fact that it
has an FN on it at this point will be
deemed to be
irrelevant representative mc mc um NAB
not McNab but NAB thank you I like McNab
though that's good um thank you Mr chair
thank you members of the committee for
having me again Alison NAB ringham 12
representing stratum in New Hampshire um
680 FN is similar to the previous two
bills that we've been discussing the
only difference is that it does allow a
homeowners association to assign charges
for a shared meter back to the unit
sharing that meter splitting equally
instead of passing it back to all
members of the association so um the
amendment that I have provided you adds
back in the Electric Co-op that was
inadvertently left out and that's part
of the previous two bills that you've
heard as one of the utilities impacted
um so uh I don't have much more to say
I'll just say you know sort of big
picture again I think this is a matter
of fairness it comes down to whether you
believe members of a condo in a
residential condo association should be
charged at a commercial rate or if they
should be charged as residents as a
single family home would so I I respect
the concerns that the department of
energy has and that eversource expressed
about allowing an association to make
the determination as to whether they're
residential or or commercial and maybe
that's something that needs to be better
teased out in the legislation but um I
think inherently we're talking about
charging water and septic to Condo
Association members at a residential
rate they are residents they're not
commercial entities whether you want to
use the term commercial or not they are
not inherently commercial entities so um
I'm happy to take any questions but I
don't think I have anything further on
this
bill okay questions representative
Arrington
thank you chairman thank you for taking
my question I I understand what you're
trying to do here which which seems
pretty fair that the um you're saying
that since the residents and they're
using it for well and septic just like I
use for well and septic I should pay the
residential rate I guess my question is
as was discussed earlier is there
another alternative I mean could this be
done internally for instance the
president of the condo association puts
that group meter in their name and then
the condo association has rules that
says you know the president shall be
buildt for the group meter and they this
this charge shall be equally divided
among the condo associate members and
paid to the president on a monthly basis
I mean wouldn't that just take care of
the problem without
legislation yes I mean it sounds like it
is a non-legislative solution to me it
feels a little bit funny because you're
saying it's fine as long as it's in a
different name right I mean the
situation hasn't changed it's still
these homeowners is still condo members
you're you're putting the onus on a
condo association to run this internally
on their own and a single individual to
be billing out to people um it is a
solution I think to me it feels a little
bit funny because it's like you're doing
something secretive that everyone says
is fine um just to make it utility
regulation sorry yeah welcome to the
world of uation familiar with it a lot
cooky so representative NAB on a similar
in a similar vein if you look down at
line 22 23 24
25 it says when fixing rates for
electric electricity the commission
shall
classify and it uses the word
classify residential units in homeowners
customers etc etc etc I don't know that
the
a residential unit in a homeowners
association I I think that might be
outside
the the
statutory authority of the Public
Utilities Commission
so I would personally judge that this
particular version of the three bills
and I haven't unfortunately been here to
to hear all the discussion about the
previous two but but this one in
particular I would think this probably
isn't workable language might even be uh
unconstitutional the way it's worded so
we might have to to to think about a
different solution for that one
now since you're here can you explain to
us some email that we got from the prime
sponsor explaining
that the operational plan and for these
three bills is to create an amendment
that puts them all together in a single
bill is that
still a plan and and do you know how it
would work
exactly um thank you for the question I
think that is still the intention I
think uh she recognized in reviewing the
three bills for today that they are very
similar and don't necessarily need to be
separate bills and it sounds like some
tweaking needs to be done um I take your
comment on the Pu you're more familiar
with the Pu than I am surely but um I
think that is still the intention and I
I think the the dream would be that
someone on this committee who's also
well versed in this or well versed in
the Pu would be interested in working on
that Amendment um but if that's not the
case we could certainly work on creating
an amendment that combines the three
bills so that two of them could be ited
and one could be moved
forward thank you additional questions
representative
McGee thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative na take my question
so I'm looking at the language of the
bill that um chairman Vose just
mentioned around whether the Public
Utilities Commission would be or should
be classifying residential uh units in
homeowners associations as anything
specific and I understand that what
you're trying to satisfy is to try and
get some uniformity from the utilities
in this case it's Unitil but just in
general you want some language that
covers homeowners not even though your
particular case right um so I was
wondering if if we uh if we amended the
language that says classify to something
that isn't that doesn't have
um the same connotation but has the
meaning that you're trying to get at
like if they identify this class or if
they uh uh treat this class or you know
um consider consider yeah I was that I
was thinking of that earlier thank you
Michael yeah that they would consider
right that that then at least there
would be statutory language that would
give you the definitional framework that
you want but it doesn't require that the
Pu do anything
specific does that sound like a
possibility for the amendment because
I'm just thinking if you could solve the
problem that the chair brought up as
well if you're coming back with a a more
a more fome uh singular Bill Amendment
then uh that might be a good thing to
think about sure I think that makes
sense thank you for the question
comments
additional questions representative rols
thank you Mr chairman yeah just one more
um substantive sort of
clarification question here on the
substance of the of the issue is is the
existance of the problem that this bill
is is aiming to
solve related to the physical
construction sometimes of Condominiums
where you know obviously there they're
joining units there's all different
shapes the way a building might be built
and and this problem has arisen where
you know the three units at the end
share a meter for their septic pump and
so you know there's just one pump is
that hang hang on a second is that the
question is that hang on a second please
is that where it originates there is a
member speaking so if you could hold
private conversations uh to a minimum or
take them outside we'd appreciate that
thank you please continue thank you Mr
chairman yeah so is it is it a physical
construction problem is that where this
issue arises sure I think that can be
the case and I think Mr SWAT could speak
better to that because I think in the
case of The Vineyards that is one of the
the issues that has caused this problem
is the way that the condo association
was designed but I would defer to him to
representative Matson has a question I
was wondering what you would think we
could do in the case of where some of
the condos are actually commercial and
the rest of them are residential so that
well sure and I think in one of the
previous bills it really delineates that
these are meant to be for only
residential condos so I don't believe
it's the case where you have a common
that this would apply I think it's in
situations where it's all residential
and again as the non-prime sponsor don't
quote me on that but that's my
understanding from the the language of
the
legislation representative Harrington
thank you and thank you for taking my
question I just um with this the there's
been a lot of discussion here on this uh
commission shall classify I wonder if
something uh like this would appear to
work better uh when assigning the rates
for electricity the utility shall
consider residential units in homeowners
associations as residential customers to
me that gets away from the because it's
actually the I believe it's just the
utility that's actually doing the
assignment of the rate based on their
tariff and I don't know if you think
that would be
helpful um I think it's slightly above
my pay grade as to my understanding of
the utility versus the Pu so um I think
it's a great comment and I would take it
into
a better understanding of tweaking this
language as to which would be a better
fit um and you know maybe that's a
conversation to have with them and ever
sourcing
unitel to follow on with that in line
seven it says the commission shall
ensure that all homeowners associations
blah blah blah once again that probably
should be that the utilities should
insure not not the commission I don't
think that's that that that's part of
the commission's charge
right
questions seeing none well thank you
representative for introducing this
legislation thank you call next on Miss
energy good morning again M uh Mr chair
and members of the committee I'm Megan
Stone legislative leaon with the
Department of energy uh the department
is neutral on this bill as introduced um
but we do have concerns with it um first
of all the public I'm sorry uh even if
homeowners associations are 501c3 not
for-profit entities they are still a
type of Corporation are required to
register as a business with Secretary of
State the department does not see how
homeowners associations can be Del ated
as residential any residential customer
applying for service would be build
under the applicable residential rate
while any commercial customer or
business entity would be build at the
applicable commercial rate um
furthermore the Public Utilities
Commission sets rate for different rates
for different rate classes as defined in
the utility tariff New Hampshire's
electric utilities classify service
broadly as commercial or reg residential
with different rate options available
within each broad rate class the
department does not believe the
commission would have the authority or
resources to ensure how homeowners
associations are built um and lastly
this is just for informational purposes
uh State Statute only permits shared
meters in certain instances this is only
allowed in the state adopted addition of
international building code and
international energy conservation code
or as amended by uh local governments
I'm happy to take any
questions Vice chair Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my
question a thought occurred to me if
this bill or any of them would pass
would this have any implications with
RPS Reggie net metering uh solar
subsidies anything like that would that
have any implications with any of those
programs I would have to get back to you
um on
so miss Stone did I under understand you
to say that the department believes
of declaring that a homeowners
association is a
501c3
entity in the eyes of the secretary of
state that autom automatically makes it
a business or commercial property yes
okay thank you all right uh further
questions from Miss
Stone seeing none thank you very much
thank
you last word on this uh legislation
goes to
Richard Sweat Richard sweat of uh
stratum representing
nhlc I suspect you've already spoken on
this on this issue but we'll give you
Mr sweat the floor is yours thank you
very much I would like to say one thing
about this incorporation or
unincorporated business a Condominium
Association can be
unincorporated under
356b there is no need for a Condominium
Association to become Incorporated it
can remain unin Incorporated to be
incorporated is an option provided to
Condominiums if it is incorporated it
gets Incorporated under RSA
2922 and it uh and that is where you
register with the New Hampshire
Secretary of State and you res register
as a domestic nonprofit corporation the
statement of purpose is stated in that
form and basically the state statement
of purpose would say it is a residential
type corporation uh form for the benefit
of the residents so in our case The
Vineyards was unincorporated in 2014 it
decided to become Incorporated but legal
attorneys today give the advice to
Condominiums to remain unincorporated
and go back to being unincorporated
under RSA 3 56b so
uh it all I'm saying is there are
unincorporated corporate uh associations
and an
incorporated Association could give up
its incorporation status and go back to
be unincorporated so anyway I just
wanted to clear that up okay so anyway
I've spoken before so you know my Bon
aides
here um let me get on to this particular
one this is this is an interesting one
no doubt about it uh
basically it says that all shared
residential electric meters serving
residential units for domestic purposes
such as well and well pumps and septic
systems shall be built at the
residential rate we've been through this
before now in many condominium
associations the developer installed
shared residential electric meters
serving domestic purposes such as well
pumps and SE IC Systems in accordance
with utility plans approved by the
municipal and state authorities so the
developer got approval to do these plans
the Condominium Act 356b states that
condominium declaration shall name the
condominium which name shall include the
word condominium Condominiums as I said
can remain unincorporated or
Incorporated now whether you're
incorporated or
unincorporated associations manage the
association's payment of vendors
providing services to limited common
areas and limited common areas are owned
jointly by all the residents in The
Vineyards Association we have 76 units
all the common areas 176 of them are
owned by the residents they're owned by
the residents okay no commercial
ownership there at all anyway so the
common area the facilities such as
utility bills insurance premiums
contractors performing replacement
maintenance and repair service onc
common areas now if this payment method
were not in place it would go back to
what you ask the every Source person
every the the vendor would have to bill
76 unit owners separately for the
service they provide now in the case
where it's build to the management
company who is serving at
the request or at the option of the of
the association to provide the service
it provides a service to the vendor and
to the association so that 100 that 76
bills don't have to be sent out to each
s so this payment process benefits it in
vendors contracts doing business with
the
association HB 680 amends 370 87 such as
the commission Bill all residential
units at residential rates even if the
association is paying the bills on
behalf of individual residential units
in the case of The
Vineyards
Unitil bills us on the bill it states
the address where the billing is it
states that the customer is The
Vineyards of condominial Association and
it goes it's it care of great North
management company which is our
management company which pays the bills
so that's how that works and anyway uh
now you had a question of moving from
commercial to residential that was that
would be difficult to do the reason
being if you're more than 10 units you
have to go before the consumer
protection board and provide fill out a
form saying that you're now a
residential unit now I suppose it could
be done but I don't think there would be
any commercial activities in it now
getting back to how easy it is to
identify a residential condomin it's
very easy all you have to go is go to
the registry of dates and look at the
condominium declaration the condominium
declaration is going to say whether
you're residential or commercial you can
uh would be another you could as I said
before you could ask the the uh consumer
Bureau of protection if there's more
than 10 residential units you can ask
them if that Condominium Association is
registered as a residential unit it's
not difficult to to find and Define a
residential unit so anyway uh the
vineyard board of directors and the
condom Leadership Council support the
passage of
hb680
thank
you okay thank you Vice chair Thomas has
a question question uh thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question just curious what what happens
if um one or two or a few more of your
residential condos are actually running
a business out of their condo could
could be mail orderer business or or or
other type maybe they're giving haircuts
inside there I don't know but what
happens if they are running a retail uh
uh business out well matter of fact we
did have that case with one of our uh
unit owners and what what they did they
installed a separate meter that would
register the meter for their business
and the reason they did it was because
they could take a deduction on their
business tax for
electric electric usage so the answer is
it did happen in our unit in our
Condominium Association and that unit
owner had unitel install a third another
usage representative Summers has a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question this is just a
quick one and it may have been covered
earlier I just want to make sure about I
know this legislation these last three
bills have had particularly had to do
with Condominiums and with this
legislation particular Condominiums how
does the I understand the different
rates commercial rate versus uh versus
residential but how would this differ
from apartment buildings multif family
residences town home associations
homeowner associations how how would
that how do Condominiums differ from
those and is there a particular reason
why this only goes at
Condominiums well one of the reasons is
that the Condominium Act
356 uh B defines Condominiums now if you
have a an apartment owner that's usually
owned by a company or a corporation
which are in the business of collecting
rents of making a profit of uh filing
taxes for depreciation commercial
purposes uh you know uh condominium is
is
by is is is defined by legislation uh I
mean I I that's the best way I can
question okay uh representative Wendy
Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair um my
question was um we this morning we have
heard I'm sorry this morning we have
heard three condominium bills in a row
one two three you've testified at each
of them do you see any conflict between
together no I don't see any conflict on
them working together I would say I
would agree with uh representa NAB and
representative Manos that uh it would
have been more efficient if they were
put into into into one bill I will
certainly say that but I mean that's my
answer to your question thank you no
that helps thank you representative
Harrington has a question thank you
thank you take my question looking at
this it seems like the the whole uh
essence of this issue comes down to
these couple of lines on uh line 22 and
23 uh in the latest Bill we're looking
at here and if it was to say something
like like when assigning the rates for
electricity the utility shall consider
residential units in homeowners
association as residential customers and
ensure that all billing etc etc well the
whole nub of that comes down to then is
shall consider residential units in
homeowners association as residential
customers how would it would be defined
what a residential unit is and who is
responsible for doing that
well you can Define it
by one once again go to the condominium
declaration it would say it's a
residential unit Mr chairman I just
wanted to clarify my question a little
bit because I think I hang on and let
him okay elaborate yeah you can you can
Define it by going on looking at the
condominium declaration which is
required under
356b it'll
say the intent of the condomini it would
also give the plan that the condominium
has and it would also give a description
of the units
itself uh what was the second part of
your question I kind of forgot well what
I wanted to get to because I didn't make
I apologize for the question wasn't very
clear I I understand what you've been
saying that this is defined in various
documents and so forth but okay now you
your utility and you you got a new
condominium and they come say I want
electricity to you know all the units
and plus we want and we have a joint um
account that's going to supply the
septic and the well to the uh
condominium now the utility says okay
and these are all going to Residential
Properties well so who does what at that
point is the utility supposed to go
research this are you supposed to get
all this paperwork together and file it
with the utility and they review it and
then say Oh okay we consider you based
on what you submitted a residential
customer or is that what the what's the
yard stick the utility will use uh in
order to make that determination frankly
I have no idea I would certainly say
that that yard stick probably ought to
be incorporated in the
Pu uh tariff that basically reg
regulates domestic uh uh units I mean it
could basically say uh it could
basically say if you want a residential
rate make an application to the utility
and provide the reason you want a
residential rate such as under our
condominium okay additional
questions I would like to ask one um and
then I'll get to you representative
Swanson because I haven't heard you
speak before I missed your your first
two um uh appearances before the mic can
this problem be solved by the homeowners
in other words can the rules of the
homeowners
association determine how to divvy up
the cost of
the well the rules do divvy up the cost
it basically says that the utility costs
are shared 176 by all the uh all the
units and and that and those costs are
included in the budget that the
homeowners have approved for the year
here so if the homeowners have approved
the budget of $10,000 for utility bills
it's included in their condominium fees
uh at 176 of the
cost so then the issue just becomes
making sure that the utility builds the
homeowners association at residential
rates versus commercial rates that would
be
true okay got it representative Swanson
has a
question uh thank you Mr chair thank you
Mr sweat for being here and uh with
regard to the it was mentioned earlier
about the uh language in the uh the bill
and reference to the commissioner shall
ensure that all homeowners in one part
and then another part the commissioner
shall classify residential units uh to
your knowledge do you have any issues if
that uh term the commissioner would be
changed to the utility this is a uh
lines 7 through
n of page one and lines 22 through 23 of
page one well I did not bring that
particular wait I've got
it could you could you repeat those
lines again so uh right in House Bill
680 right so page one line 7 through 8
refer to the commission shall ensure and
also below that uh lines 22 and
23 the commission shall classify are two
Clauses that are in there and uh would
that be any problem as far as you're
concerned if that was changed to the
utility shall ensure versus the
commission shall
ensure I'm really not sure I understand
that question I mean the the Public
Utility Commission
uh approves the rate tariffs that the
utilities present to them so I'm not
question um I'm not sure how to rephrase
it so I'll defer it this time if
somebody can clarify my question because
it was brought up earlier about the term
the commission shall earlier Mr
chair okay maybe Mr lot can some shed
some uh light on that and he'll be
testifying in just a minute okay thank
you Mr sweat are there any further
SWAT seeing none thank you sir
appreciate you being here and now Mr
Lata will come back up and um maybe have
some new information that he's gathered
uh that he can share Mr
Lata uh again for the record Michael
AATA representing eversource energy
apologies I don't have new information
to share but uh I did want to just
respond to I guess some of the
uh thoughts of members of the committee
about different responsibilities of of
different entities uh so not on the
underlying bill but uh I think it's
it's in response to some of the
questions from representative Harrington
and and representative Swanson um
so it's been disc
whether to give the utility the
responsibility to to ensure that um the
customer is a condo association that
they're using uh would be using this
electricity for shared residential
services and I just wanted to be very
clear the utility doesn't have the
ability to to make those determinations
or do audits essentially what you if you
were to move in that Direction you would
be setting up a system where a
commercial entity would be self-
declaring to the
utility that they are a condo
association they are a homeowners
association that this is used for septic
or portable water and the utility would
accept that self declaration um we we
you know wouldn't be going out and and
you know doing field audits of these
these ities I presume you wouldn't want
us to do that because of the expense
involved so again as you consider
different options for these bills and
placing um different responsibilities I
just wanted to point out from
eversource's perspective you know there
are limitations to what we can ensure
and we would be relying uh I believe
obviously depending on on how this would
all be structured on the entity to
self-certify to us that they are
sort of this unique class of customer
you know a homeowners association that
are using shared services for specific
residential purposes so just again in
response to some of the concepts being
discussed uh just trying to think
through practically how the utility
would would try to manage that uh and
again I I'd be happy to answer any
so would you
not do you think it should be the
commission's responsibility to ensure
and or classify or do you think that
should happen in
scenarios I guess you're so I am not
familiar in any meaningful way other
than having just heard the citation with
RSA 356
uh so I don't know what is required of a
condomini Association a homeowners
association what documentation they have
to provide
to any entity in the state of New
Hampshire whether it's the secretaries
of Secretary of State's office or
otherwise in order to come into fruition
and so I don't know if there is a uh
within state government a an entity that
has reports and documentation of the
existence of these entities that either
the Public Utilities Commission could
could use to verify or or any other
entity and so I think absent that and
again it very well may exist I I am not
the expert uh but absent that I think
any entity would be relying on you know
this Association to do that
self-reporting uh and and you know would
have limited ability to
verify this statutory language says on
line 22 when fixing rates for
electricity the commission
shall does the commission fix rates for
electricity I thought the utilities did
that so the the
utilities uh proposed rates to the
Public Utilities Commission through a
number of different adjudications uh
there are distribution rates that are
are set through periodic rate cases
there are transmission rates that are
set every six months there are energy
Supply rates as the committee is is well
aware and so it would be the
commission's approval of the utilities
proposed rates is is essentially so they
are the rate sent setting entity whether
use fixed or or otherwise but um there
are obviously they're ultimately
approving the rates that the utilities
set
so at the very least the language should
say when approving rates for electricity
yes okay thank you further questions
representative M uh McGee thank you Mr
chair thank you Mr Lata for taking my
question so it sounds like we're
grappling back and forth with um the
language as it exists but from what I've
heard since I've been here um it it it
appears to me that perhaps it's the
utility that we're really talking about
in terms of servicing these homeowners
associations and viewing them as res as
having a residential rate apply to them
so is there some meaningful way that we
can make that clarification based on the
utilities because that seems to be where
the issue is with the folks that brought
forth the bill they're just trying to
Grapple with how to solve it sure uh as
I said on the other Bill the
utility
um is not privy to what goes on behind
the meter and so if a commercial entity
applies for service then they are
charged a commercial rate if a
residential homeowner or apartment you
know residential um uh customer applies
for service they're given the
residential rate and so the utility is
blind to what the commercial entity does
afterwards and so ultimately if it's the
determination of the legislature to say
we're creating a new class of customer
and we want you to say if it's a uh
homeowners association or a Condominium
Association nonprofit to treat them as
um as a residential customer then you
know we we will do that what I'm
pointing out here is we'll have no way
of verifying that that commercial
Enterprise does what it is telling us it
does representative Bernardi has a
question thank you Mr chair uh so again
I'm pivot off of uh a suggestion by
representative Harrington would it be uh
a unacceptable solution from the utility
perspective if this legislation
basically said homeowners associations
or condo
associations that have common
Residential Services must identify a
single entity the president the
secretary of the association whatever as
the
residential bill
collector or Bill
addressy would that I I think that would
solve
this so I is that unacceptable to the
utilities yeah I think I don't want to
sort of speak in the moment without
being able to sort of review a proposal
But ultimately as we discussed
previously if it's in the name of a
residential customer they will get
charged the residential rate and however
they collect it sounds from 70 or so um
that representative
Harrington yeah so it sounds like in lie
of what was just Des discussed and
having an actual resident do it there
the problem with having the com the U
Condo Association be the billing
recipient is that there's no real
definition of what constitutes a
residential customer so from the point
of view of the utility if there was some
type of a filing that a condo
association could make with the
secretary of state or whatever saying or
maybe the Pu saying uh we we're going to
make this filing because we propos that
all the usage of this electricity is
going to be used by for residential
purposes by residential customers and
then the Pu is issues them I don't know
a certificate of residence or something
and then when you go to Bill they say
I'm a residential customer here's my
certificate does that make your problem
go
away
um again would want to actual actually
review language but you know if you have
City presumably that it could beway
thank
you representative McGee thank you Mr
chair and I just wanted to make a point
that um I believe that Mr SWAT um
testified that the secretary of state
does have a list of the homeowners
associations so I'm just wondering if
there seems like we could maybe connect
the dots in terms of you're saying you
have no idea what's going on behind that
but if they are to be in a in a separate
category because they're Incorporated
not Incorporated you could probably find
that information if you were if you were
servicing the area so I'm just wondering
if they're um if you would agree that
that is something that could potentially
be
uncovered again I'm not familiar with um
356b and
what requirements are uh are in place
however if um you know if an association
is required to uh register with the
secretary of state and they were to
provide uh evidence of that registration
at the time of uh starting
service I guess it's sort of similar to
representative Harrington's thought
perhaps that could be um an option that
would not still it's a public policy
determination but you know I'm sort of
testifying on the perspective of the
utility that we don't want to take on
additional administrative
burdens all right we seem to be going in
circles here so I think U we've beat
this horse about as
uh significantly as we can obviously we
have some work to do to figure out how
to proceed here but um I think we can
maybe think about forming a subcommittee
to
to hammer out a final solution for this
bill and um
so let's talk about doing that um let me
see a show of hands of people who would
be willing to serve on a subcommittee on
this bill I see
yeah we'll
volte all right so uh I will appoint
representative Bernardi to the
subcommittee and the first named person
to the subcommittee will be the
subcommittee's chair I will appoint
representative reels I will appoint
representative
McGee I will appoint representative
Harrington
how many is that I lost that's three I
guess we
need let's do five
maybe so representative Corman and
that that's
five all right so we have a subcommittee
it's the responsibility of the
subcommittee chair to schedule
subcommittee
meetings so keep your eye out on the
calendar for a subcommittee meeting on
this question and representative NAB you
should be alert to subcommittee meetings
on this subject as will representative
Manos I'm sure and
um the subcommittee can decide what's
the best way to proceed to to solve this
problem so with that I'm going to close
the public hearing on House Bill 6
80- FN it is now 12 minutes or so before
maybe 15 minutes before 11: and I'm
going to ask that everybody in the room
clear out so that we can have a
republican caucus I would like all
members to be back in the room by
11:05 at which time there may be an
executive
e
okay welcome back
everyone so the meeting notice for the
public hearings that we had scheduled
for today contains the following langu
language executive session on pending
legislation may be held throughout the
day time permitting from the time the
committee is initially con
convened that language which is in-house
rules allows us to take advantage of
time opportunities which we have here
this morning because it is still too
early to go to lunch but we have some
time on our hands therefore I'm going to
open a couple of exec sessions the first
exec session will be on House Bill
hc4 house continuing resolution four and
I'm going to recognize representative
motion thank you Mr chair uh on the uh
on
hc4 my motion is to
OTP I recognize representative
Matson thank you Mr chair and I second
the motion it's been moved and seconded
that we adopt the motion of OTP on
HCR 4 discussion representative Vice
chair
Thomas thank you Mr chairman as I
iterated yesterday this resolution is
designed to send a message to
our federal legislation legislation to
our governor and to the surrounding
states that there are severely
unanswered questions that have uh
affected our fishermen who in my opinion
and I believe truly they know their
ocean best and these questions have not
been thoroughly vetted or answered for a
long time that could affect the food
chain their livelihood environmental
concerns of the
seabed ETC as well as undetermined costs
of what it might cost the rayer based on
examples that we have seen around the
world and until and until those
questions are thoroughly vetted and
answered to everyone's satisfaction that
New Hampshire declares that we uh
categorically reject offshore wind uh in
the Gulf of Maine and we also ask and
call upon the surrounding states to uh
look at this as well and to uh talk to
their fishermen uh for a perhaps a
similar determination but for right now
we don't believe that offshore wind is
right for New Hampshire and uh because
there are so many unanswered questions
and these the uh testimony we received
yesterday was was very adeptly um uh
spoken to by several members of the
fisherman's Association uh on potential
uh harming effects of the water in in
seab bid so with those that things in
mind I believe we should pass this
resolution further
discussion representative
nter thank you Mr chairman yesterday's
hearings were very educational and I en
enjoy hearing from the fishermen and um
the others who testified and um talking
about the circle of life in the ocean
and how everything in the ocean is there
to be eaten by something else in the
ocean and and how disruptive these
windmills are we we also learned about
how um potentially dangerous they are
with um with how they're made you know
they have these toxic chemicals and they
talked about the one that broke so um
I'll be voting for it to pass this bill
as well additional conversation uh
discussion representative McGee thank
you Mr chairman so um I also found the
uh testimony of the fisherman quite
compelling yesterday and I think that
there are many issues that need to be uh
accommodated and investigated I don't
believe that New Hampshire should close
the door on participating in the process
to figure out whether this is a a
solution that can assist the area I also
think it makes no sense for us to be
rejecting out of hand something where we
really haven't been at the table for
that long um to
have the answers to the questions that
we're talking about here the hearing
didn't answer a lot of the questions
about the technology there there needs
to be a lot more and obviously if it is
going to go forward it's something
that's being pressed by the federal
government and that may be changing I
don't see any reason for us to make a
statement that we are um as our
utilities mentioned and others viia you
know if we're in all of the above
strategy then we shouldn't be uh pi
winners and losers and saying we can't
do this one they all have downsides and
we've had that discussion before as
well representative Harrington thank you
um well first of just be clear this
doesn't this is the bill that just gets
the state government office out and says
there's a lot of cautions that we need
to put in place and a lot of things we
and no this is sorry this is the res
this is the resolution one okay I'm
sorry wrong bill got it confused but the
um the one thing I did want to bring up
is that this has been looked at for
quite some time I've been a member of
the offshore wind commission for a few
years now and uh of all the people that
spoke there other than people from bone
uh which is u a government agency I
didn't hear a single person speak in
favor of it and at the last meeting we
had there was probably over a 100 people
for the public to come to a a commission
meeting like that is I don't know how
many you've been two of different ones
but I've never seen that big of an
outpouring of people and not a single
person spoken in favor of the bill so um
I think that uh having a resolution
saying that we want to be very cautious
going forward with wind is a good
idea representative Wendy
Thomas thank you Mr chair um there are
several um issues that I have with this
um piece of legislation first of all the
way that it's written um I used to be a
tech writer and um I would never turn in
a a document like this for example on
line 8 it says um that toxic water back
into the ocean in massive amounts well
quantify massive what is that um it also
references chlorine which we heard a lot
about which um from what I understand is
old technology and is no longer used um
there are two permits have already been
awarded for the Gulf of
Maine and we heard from testifier um
Meredith Hatfield that there have been
extensive studies into the oceans EO
ecosystem and the fishing industry and
the impact to rate payers um what we did
not hear which was in line 16 is that
this is likely to exceed current rates
again what does that mean quantify it um
lastly uh telling other states what to
do I don't think is within our purview
um and as uh to uh representative
McGee's point this removes us from from
the table and it's just not good
business practice thank you
representative
bernardy thank you Mr chair uh I have
been a member of the Coastal Marine uh
committee where this where the windmills
offshore have been a major uh subject
for several years and I've attended many
of the offshore wind committee meetings
I never have heard the fishermen get
any opportunity in any significant way
to make their case they had their best
presentation and their best uh dialogue
yesterday in this committee where they
were able to uh put on the table the
hazards of of the coatings on the blades
as well as the
chlorination of the cooling system that
are us used to in the when you Rectify
AC to DC power uh in order to transmit
that power to Shore and that is that is
a uh they gave quantities uh very
specifically of 40% utilization rate and
100% utilization rate of how many
gallons of hot chlorinated water we
going to be dumped into the ocean
unacceptable it to totally kills all the
micro uh um uh flora and fauna and and
that causes then uh a a Devastation of
the the downstream uh feeding of of any
marine life in the in the immediate area
so uh that's a major issue that needs to
get resolved uh and until that kind of
thing can be resolved
resolution further discussion
representative
Swanson thank you Mr
chair I'm just a recreational fisherman
but I like uh the commercial fishermen
appreciate the importance of the
ecosystem and uh the preservation of the
life within it and I like those
fishermen also some days wish I was
fishing but not today
um this bill is very problematic because
it feels like additional regulation and
I've heard it said that we have too much
regulation already and furthermore
there's some things that are very
ambiguous in here especially this
assertion about uh rejection of all
projects I don't know if that's supposed
to be a message to anybody who wants to
write on the back of the napkin or who
wants to prepare a submission to a
commission or really what that entails
in additional in addition I have
problems with this uh lack of definition
until such time as there is more
complete understanding where's the
definition of a more complete
understanding this is totally ambiguous
and really to me pointless so
I disapprove of this bill further
discussion
representative Vice chair Thomas thank
you Mr chair well
I'm not sure uh for the benefit of those
that are new here resolutions are
non-binding whereas bills uh other bills
that uh attack this subject uh would be
binding this resolution is non-binding
and it's non-binding for one solid
reason wind turbin or offshore wind
would be in federal waters and the state
cannot dictate by Statute what the
federal government cannot do uh when
it's not in its States territories what
what this resolution does is it merely
says we don't want offshore wind in our
fishing Waters I.E Gul of Maine um yet
because uh and it's been going on now
for years not just a short time there
are questions that have not been
answered in many cases not even have
been addressed by the the federal
government so what this resolution does
it's it sends it is sending a message to
everybody and gives backup to the
governor who has also stated during her
campaign that she is not in favor of
offshore wind it gives her legislative
backup uh on on that point and perhaps
the messaging which is meant to be
strong and is meant to say hey other
states please attention to what we're
saying we know we can't tell you what to
do but we're advising you to please look
at this because we don't think it's a
good idea that maybe some of these
questions will be answered to someone's
satisfaction and even the fishermen here
said that they are not closing the door
on this uh until questions are answered
so this resolution is merely a statement
saying hey we don't want this because of
the various reasons and that's why we
have all those reasons listed
representative
rols thank you Mr chairman um as a
representative of
Portsmouth um a city which hosts a
fishing
fleet and as a retired Coast Guard
officer who has been on and around the
ocean for my entire professional
career uh I've been to see in in the
Gulf of
Maine
um I appreciate and respect the input
from the fisherman that we heard
yesterday
um however there was also a lot of
misinformation
coming and
uh such as
the the gentleman who stated that um
because the turbin would be floating
turbines and have anchor chains on them
that no vessels would be able to enter
into the entire area of the floating
wind turbines that's just not
correct uh anything that's floating and
anchored in the
water as they stated the
uh lengths of those chains might might
be as big as that desk well those chains
hang straight down okay yes uh at Great
depth there's a catary but
uh nothing like that would prevent ships
from passing
within even 50 or 100 yards of of all of
these floating turbines and so it's not
as though there would be this huge area
of the ocean off limits to Mariners and
uh where fishermen in distress couldn't
be rescued and all of that I just I just
had to call that out that one in
particular
um but this is just not um the kind
of blanket statement that the state of
New Hampshire should be
making uh again as a representative
Portsmouth where the city's only sea
port is located uh the port of
Portsmouth uh and in particular the
about to be decommissioned uh Schiller
Power Station both uh could be
significantly involved in an offshore
wind industry and there could be
significant Economic Development benefit
from the port of Portsmouth being
involved in
staging uh construction and management
of uh offshore
wind
installations so taking a blanket
position that we reject it all until as
my colleague just stated the UN
defined better understanding is reached
is just not um not good public policy
resolution okay everybody has had a
chance to weigh in on this issue I don't
think we need to have multiple
statements about it once you've stated
your position we understand it so uh I
would like to ask the clerk to call the
role on the question of the adoption of
4 M sh Thomas yes representative ner yes
representative Harrington yes
representative Bernardi yes
representative PL yes representative
Summers yes representative Matson yes
representative schneller yes
representative McGee no representative
Thomas excuse me Wendy Thomas
no representative Howard
no Representative
rolds no representative ra relle no
represent representative Swanson no
chairman Vose
yes two three four five six seven eight
nine 2 one two three four five six by a
vote of 9 to six the motion of ought to
pass is adopted for HCR
4 Vice chair Thomas will write the
you okay there will be a Minority Report
tomorrow and with
that Mr chair um the clerk tells me we
need an author for The Minority
Report you can put representative McGee
will Author The Minority Report
representative
Thomas yes thank you um do we have a
print out of the bills that we're going
over right now
uh each of us received a print out
yesterday
yes all right with that we're going to
close the public the executive session
on house continuing resolution 4 and I'm
going to open a exec session on House
Bill
682 and I'll recognize representative
Summers for a
motion thank you Mr chair I make the
motion ought to pass on HB 682
chair recognizes representative
Harrington I second the motion moved and
seconded that we adopt the motion of a
to pass on House Bill
682 chair
recognizes representative Summers thank
you Mr chairman so after watching
multiple hours of testimony yesterday
from all the folks that came in and tied
to the last HCR we just discussed I was
impressed by the experience the research
and the technical the technical
knowledge of the fisheries and what they
had to speak for them yesterday and
especially what stood up to me was Mr
Len when he came out there and he spoke
not only which important to me is an
Academia important with research but the
research was peer-reviewed there's
nothing more sacred in Academia than
peer-reviewed articles and that is what
B all research is based on so with he
came out with peer-reviewed articles
talking about the chlorination the
chemicals in the water the disruption of
the Plankton the effect of the small
fish the the uh with the shellfish
fishing lobsters the way it was changed
with them and of the uh also brought up
the uh effect on
whales now um and lastly I mean there
was also right now there's currently an
executive order in effect blocking all
offshore wind and it must be a real
battle for those for those that on the
other side that are for off where they
have chosen the importance of offshore
wind and taken the Precedence of
paa okay discussion on HB 682
representative Wendy Thomas
thank you um Mr chair as was stated
during the testimony um this bill would
remove New Hampshire from the discussion
of of wind power completely and it's
very clear that we need more power in
New Hampshire because we are not energy
independent we don't have oil we don't
have gas um we're already seeing the
impacts of these maybe tariffs from
Canada um the other thing that this bill
is it does not remove the renewable
energy task force however it neuters it
by removing all of its tasks and
responsibilities I will be voting
against this Bill thank
you I think you're incorrect about the
bill completely removing New Hampshire
from a discussion of offshore wind
because while it does repeal the
commission and some other Associated
language about offshore wind the office
of energy Innovation which would be the
new title of that office will continue
to have authority to watch what happens
with offshore wind other discussion
representative Harrington yeah yeah as
far as that goes is with the interaction
with other states the department of
energy still represents New Hampshire at
all the iso New England and neol various
meetings where potential win projects
would be discussed so we're definitely
going to be involved in that through
that and through n go so it's it's not
like we're uh boarding up around here
the the other thing to remember is that
there has never been an offshore wind
project proposed to be built in the
United States that wasn't mandated by a
state government so right now New
Hampshire has no such mandate lacking
that a you there's no utility in New
Hampshire that could turn around and say
I want to build offshore wind so we
haven't even got to the step where we
would allow that to happen because they
don't generate we reregulate we
deregulate that now in the case of
Massachusetts and Connecticut and other
states the um government tells the
utility you will negotiate with the
offshore wind company and you will enter
into a purchase power agreement with
them so that's quite a ways down the
road from where we are right now that
doesn't even allow our utilities to do
that so I don't think we're cutting
ourselves out of anything the uh doe
Will Keep Us involved through their
monthly meetings with uh ISO New England
nepool and Nesco as well
it's also worthwhile to point out that
New Hampshire is not the only state
that's backing away from offshore wind
just today the governor of New Jersey
announced that New Jersey is stepping
away from offshore wind off the coast of
New Jersey they will no longer pursue
offshore wind
projects additional comment
representative n thank you just to add
to what you just said um it was in New
Jersey where they had the issue with the
right
will right uh representative
Swanson uh as indicated given that New
Hampshire does not have a mandate to
build windmills I am unsure why uh the
whole concept of the technology seems to
be posing a threat and why we need to
change our legislation in order to
Simply overly state that we shouldn't be
pursuing this or at least we shouldn't
have uh the structure in place to
examine it and so I think I see this as
anti- business anti- technology and
that's really all it's accomplishing I
recommend against this additional
comment representative McGee um and just
looking at the bill um we we talk in
generalities a lot because it's a lot
shorter to do so so the first section
removes um offshore wind uh from the
definition in the office of energy
Innovation um but then we're also
repealing the offshore wind industry
Workforce Training Center where we were
trying to figure out whether uh
universities um and other groups would
be trying to get younger people in the
workforce trained for those jobs of the
future um and you may be able to say
well we think that's premature but the
third thing it does is it moves the grid
modernization advisory company Council
into the department of energy and the
hydrogen advisory Council into the
office of energy Innovation um I would I
would argue that having the grid
modernization advisory Council become
part of the doe removes the transparency
that it currently has now similar to the
Energy Efficiency and sustainable energy
board which we have never heard about
any activities going on uh the function
of that group was absorbed into the
Department of energy as well so um I'm
going to oppose the bill because there
are a number of things that I disagree
with and um and I don't believe that we
should be putting our heads in the sand
at this point we're not committed to
anything so again um to representative
Swanson's point I don't see why we
should be threatened by having greater
knowledge we all talk here as though
because we had a hearing yesterday we
all have knowledge we all have opinions
we don't have knowledge on the subject
of offshore wind and its viability so
I'll be opposing the
bill okay seeing no further discussion
needed I'll ask the clerk to call the
role on the question of the motion of
682 Vice chair Thomas yes representative
ner yes representative Harrington yes
representative Bernardi yes
representative PL yes representative
Summers yes representative Matson yes
representative schneller yes
representative McGee no representative
Thomas uh Wendy Thomas
no representative Howard no
Representative rolds
no representative La relle no
representative Swanson no chairman Vose
yes 9 to6 by a vote of nine to six the
motion of ought to pass is adopted for
House Bill
682 representative Summers will write
the majority report which is due by 7
am. tomorrow morning please and will
there be a Minority Report yes uh
representative Wendy Thomas will write
it representative Wendy Thomas will
write The Minority Report that's due by
7 am tomorrow morning
please and with that we'll close the
executive session on House Bill
[Music]
682 so we can now uh break for lunch
unless there are any announcements that
anyone would like to make I'd like to
remind everyone that at 2:30 this
afternoon we will have a noticed
executive
session that was noticed in the calendar
and we will be passing judgment on six
different bills during that executive
session
so I look forward to seeing you all then
we will resume our activity at 1 p.m.
with a public hearing on House Bill 654
FN we'll follow that with public
hearings on HB 541 and sb4 and then
we'll go into executive session
immediately following so that's our
schedule for the remainder of the day
we'll see you all back here at 1:00
um Can the Democrats hold back in the
room so we can figure out what we're
doing
right
e
okay good afternoon everyone welcome
back to the science technology and
energy committee meeting on Tuesday
February
4th this is the second half of our
session today we heard three bills
earlier today and we will he hear three
more in the next hour to two and a half
hours or hour and a half I should say so
the first bill we will hear is House
Bill 654 FN rela ative to allowing small
customer
generators the ability to participate in
group net
metering and following that bill we will
hear HB
541 establishing a committee to study
energy and Telecom Communications
infrastructure
survivability and
resiliency and then finally at 2:00 we
will hear s
sp4 relative to commercial property
assist clean energy and and resiliency
otherwise known as C Pacer so let's open
the public hearing right now on House
Bill 654 FN and I'll ask representative
Kat McGee to introduce this legislation
on behalf of representative Tom Corman
thank you Mr chairman and uh good good
afternoon members of the committee nice
to be back in front of you again um HB
uh
654 FN um
is uh a bill to it's very simple bill it
it will allow uh small customer
generators the ability to participate in
group net metering so um there are three
aspects under the analysis that might
help you understand the details in the
bill um basically currently small
customer generators are not allowed to
participate in group net metering and so
the first point of the bill is to allow
group hosts who who are customer
generators to form a group with any
customer including those customers who
are also generating meaning they have
solar panels on their house and I I've
heard about this issue before and uh I'm
a co-sponsor on the bill but I've really
let Tom take the lead on it because he
had been uh approached by a constituent
of his who is a former State Rep Linda
Tanner who was saying gez you know I I I
have solar panels I'd like to
participate and I find this an exclusion
here that doesn't allow me to become
part of a group that is also already net
metering and in many cases those are the
very people who would like to be
participating in sort of pooling power
um and so it seems like the
exclusion um isn't really workable so
point two is it requires any future
Rules by the commission to allow small
group small customer generators to be
members of a group foret metering
and the third part is it requires any
agency that issues rules affecting group
net metering to also ensure that small
customer generators are allowed to be
members of a group for the purpose of
net
metering so um it's pretty much all
focused on the same thing which is sort
of removing the Obstacle of allowing
somebody who's a small generator to
group okay thank you could you say a
little bit more about how this would
work since a customer
generator is someone who is a uh a
customer who is generating his own power
and probably putting the excess back on
the
grid if that person also becomes a
member of a net metering group mhm
they would get
uh as a member of the group from the
group host some power at a discount
price so if they're a customer
generator net metering and a customer
gener customer of a group net metering
group wouldn't they be double dipping in
a sense and getting double the subsidies
I was I was expecting this question um
and no one has prepped me for it but I
figured that would be one of the things
you'd want to look at I think that is
not the intent of the bill to allow
somebody to to dip in both ways the idea
is that uh if a say if a group is
forming and somebody is in that area
that wants to be part of that group if
they're currently net metering they're
not allowed to be part of that group
because of the way the language is
structured in statute so this doesn't
allow them to get credit for net
metering as an individ idual utility
customer and then also get credit for
participating in a group net metering
project it's not it's not the idea where
they'd be able to dip twice the idea is
that if they are a small generator they
should be able to join a group and
participate in that group which means
they would be um pooling their energy
with the group at least that's my
understanding I'm I'm really not you
know I didn't research this bill but I'm
pretty sure it doesn't allow double
dipping cuz I know they've been asking
for this under the limited electric
energy producers section of Statute for
a long time there's been a lot of
questions around why someone who is has
got panels on top of their house can't
be part of a group where it would make
sense for them to
be so we we may be able to get the
answer to that question better than I
can answer it from so would it be the
expectation of this legislation that the
commission would adopt a rule that says
that if you're a customer generator and
you want to become a group net metering
group member yeah you have to
stop um net metering on your own account
I would think it would be calculated one
or the other I I don't I don't see how
you would be able to double dip but
maybe somebody who runs the systems
would be able to tell you if that would
be possible I think they would have to
declare themselves part of the group
that I think that's that's the point is
that the very people who could make up
these groups in an organic way are
currently prohibited from joining the
groups because of the statute I think
that's what it's seeking to solve do you
see any language here that lays out that
distinction between being a customer
generator or being a member of a group
rather than and being a member of a
group well I think on section three um
under 362a colon 9 and it's section um
um
14 A1 it says a customer generator may
elect to become a group host for the
purpose of reducing or otherwise
controlling the energy costs of a group
of
customers and then there's language in
there now that says who are not customer
generators so what we're trying to do is
not have that be there um except U and
then it goes on to say except that a
political subdivision as divined in
another uh aspect of
362 uh or the OWN owner of a facility
described in 362
a920 that is a customer generator May
participate as a group member um so I
think I think all they're trying to do
you right now there's an exclusion for
people who are generating individually
and they want to remove that exclusion
so they can participate in the group
there isn't any language here that
explicitly says you can only count the
benefits of net metering once but it
wouldn't make sense to allow someone to
count them twice I I don't think that's
the objective of the bill but again
maybe somebody else can shed more light
on
it do do you have any idea what the
rationale behind
allowing customer generators to also be
in a group what is the rationale behind
that well I think groups are generally
trying to pull resources and um they
they have maybe more power together than
separately I I don't know I mean I think
uh many of the groups that are doing
that metering now they're they're very
different from each other so I I I'm
really don't have any expertise on
that additional questions U for
representative um McGee representative
rals well Mr chair I I don't have a
question for representative McGee but I
was wanted to ask you the chair if you
might allow me to try and help her
explain he knows more if I might try to
shed a little light for the for the
whole committee about group are you a
co-sponsor on this bill I am not no
okay you do have some expertise here
though so I will allow you to uh attempt
to explain this for us thank you Mr
chairman and I'll I'll try to be
effective OB I try to be brief um
metering the reason group net metering
exists the requirement
to for a single uh let's let's an
example one business located in an
industrial park okay right one business
located in an industrial park has a big
building they want to put solar on their
business
building um they want to put you
know uh 500 kilowatts of solar capacity
on their
building and they're going to net meter
grid the the current net the the net
metering statute requires that that uh
right they're going to send more energy
back to the Grid in a year than they
than they
use the net metering statute requires
that the the company that wants to net
load electric load essentially that
would take their electrons in theory
right you you can't control where the
electrons go
but those electrons are going to go onto
the grid so the company that wants to
net meter has to identify other
businesses and they can be anywhere in
that Utility Services territory they
don't have to be adjacent but they often
are and this might be the same for a
town that has multiple buildings that
wants to net meter so they they have to
basically sign up load to account for
the energy that they're going to put
so their neighbors neighboring
businesses might say okay you can put my
business down and here's my load and
submit that documentation to the Pu that
says now you have enough load signed up
that's going to take your net metered
electricity and that's just the
requirement of net metering it's sort of
this requirement that in theory we we're
the businesses who agree to subscribe
their load to that group group N meeting
project don't necessarily get
compensated they might they might get
compensated like the the host business
might say I'll I'll write you of of my
net metering Revenue I'll write you a
check each year to sort of pay you for
the favor of of being in my group but
they might not and in the instance of a
town with multiple buildings that are
net meeting it wouldn't make any sense
the town's not going to pay
itself so I I believe that the group the
requirement for a group for for net
metering is is sort of an accounting
exercise where
the the the the group members are not
necessarily being compensated they might
like I said if they're separate
businesses but they might not um and at
any rate the comp compensation that's
going to the group
members is
not additional rayer money it's it's
money that the host net
meter received for their exported
electricity so if he shares that Revenue
with his group members it's not
additional money so I I
believe this sit this bill is attempting
to address so you've got five buildings
in the industrial park the one puts his
big array on he signs up his neighbors
for group net metering and it happens
the way I
said but then a few years later another
business wants to put his own solar
array on and now he wants to net
meter so it it it would U allow that
person to do that while still being in
the group his load is
still part of the
load that was subscribed for the
original project but but I don't believe
there's any double dipping so I hope
that was helpful and thank
you and the other thing the other ex
sorry as I I just want to clarify what
representative rolds was trying to
explain so you think that
this legislation might primarily apply
to
situations whereby
a a municipal host
was
adding
members to its group to satisfy its load
obligation in a situation where to to
use your example let's say there's a
solar array on the town hall and there's
library right now the library couldn't
be part of the
group according to statute but if this
law if we were to adopt this legislation
the library could be part of the group
is that what you're
saying yes okay that's clarification
that's good and I just give a little bit
more on that as well the bill itself
does Define small customer generators as
a generator whose maximum total
generating capacity is not more than 100
kilowatts so it you know it it it's very
constrained in terms of those very small
generators can also be part of groups
and um I think you can derive a lot of
benefit if you have a lot of people who
are doing rooftop solar and putting them
together I know we had seen
presentations on Virtual power plants
and that kind of thing of being able to
pull it together and then say what is
the load here that can be deployed and
that kind of thing um and I think often
times this type of thing where you're
taking the sort of the many and trying
to make it into something larger that
can be deployed or used um there's a
benefit as well to resil
um so they may maybe they'll invest in
batteries and that kind of thing so that
they can deploy a certain amount of
energy onto the system if it's needed
that kind of thing so it's it's just a
tool really um representative Swanson
has a question yes thank you Mr chair uh
representative McGee what I'll do is
I'll frame this as this question in a
context okay and that may be U easier to
understand and maybe somebody who might
step up to field this might be better be
able to do this but I'll put this out
there because it's in the realm of my
experience to uh when when you install a
uh solar system and you want net
metering you pay the utility company to
come in and remove your existing meter
and replace it with a net meter so there
is a cost with doing that and uh so in
my experience I had to you know pay them
to come in put in a net meter for my
house to accommodate the solar
generation so uh there I've and for this
example I see a scenario that this would
apply to because I think many of us have
seen condos in which there is a separate
meter for each unit in the condo say a
four condo house or something like that
so there are four separate meters now
I'm living in that house or building and
I think it' be good to switch to solar
but you know I'm looking at maybe just
1/4 of all the rooftops to put solar
panels on uh but if I get together with
the other people in there uh who each
have their own meter uh collectively we
might say hey let's go to the power
company and say let's just get you know
because every solar installation has a a
fundamental built-in cost and it's
better if you do it all at once on a
given building rather than coming back
multiple times we might get together and
say well let's collaborate and uh we'll
replace our meters with a single net
meter and we'll all get solar panels and
is that kind of the scenario that this
would
support I don't know okay no I mean I
think I think I think it could the
definition of of a small generator
though is below the 100 kilowatt so it
certainly could but um but yeah okay
well thank you and maybe somebody else
can it's good scenario come up a bad
scenario thank you representative MC
questions representative Matson just for
clarification thank you just for
clarification so if all these little
small customers join together then I'm
sure they're going to be over 100
kilowatt hours doesn't that change their
where they fall in the grid I mean in
the no because that would be the group
yeah so they're they're being being
allowed to join a group as a member if
they are under 100 kilowatt so they can
throw their 100 kilow towards a larger
um group that then can you know wield
additional power
yeah that that that's the whole point is
that
um they they can maximize the power yeah
you answered the question yep okay any
other questions seeing none let's call
up next Matt Young from the Department
of energy to give us the Department's uh
legislation good afternoon Mr Young and
welcome good afternoon Mr
chairman and members of the committee
for the record my name is Matt Young and
I'm attorney at the New Hampshire
Department of
energy um the department is neutral on
HB 654 as introduced but the department
does have some
concerns um so first uh I think I'll
start uh with sort of the 30,000 foot um
consideration for this committee I think
uh the the proposed changes in HB 654 uh
do seem to violate I guess the uh what
I'll call the original intent of the
group host
designation the group host designation
was intended to permit the group host to
share any surplus power um with other
utility account holders who were not
customer generators so that so that
those customers uh could benefit from
the proceeds of renewable energy um the
group host rather than a member uh was
intended to be the owner of that
renewable energy facility so the
language included in this bill is
obviously um kind of in in conflict with
that uh perceived
intent and
then next moving on to I guess more the
more um
maybe practical uh implementation
concerns which the committee may want to
consider um so having customer
generators as group members would uh in
the Department's uh opinion greatly
complicate utility and Department
registration and administration of these
groups um so for example um this
language does permit a group host uh who
is a customer generator to be a host
themselves um which would complicate the
financial and energy usage accounting
which we sort of briefly just discussed
um and similar to what the chairman uh
had raised and which we just discussed
um the department was concerned with the
double dipping issue um and I guess I
will note uh for the chairman that I did
on my outline use the technical term
double dipping as well um and what
we we we do see a scario
where customer generators could get paid
as they normally would under that
alternative tariff and also receive
benefits as a member um as
representative Reynolds said it is um at
the group host discretion um so there
there really could be a scenario where
the member customer generator is
receiving benefits from both both
[Music]
um
and I I believe it was discussed that it
was um it it it may not end up falling
on rate payers um I I I think that based
on conversations with the utilities and
other net metering um issues that uh
this um this bill may have implications
for uh um billing and um other
accounting practices of the utilities
that would maybe require an upgrade to a
um to their to their billing systems
which which cost would ultimately get P
to the rate
payers and then finally uh which I think
I'll note you know maybe is more of a
technical fix um if this was not the
intent of the legislation line 17 does
state that the uh Public Utilities
Commission shall adopt rules to ensure
that small customer generators are
allowed to participate as members of
group net metering
and since the um sort of the the split
of the and the creation of the
Department of energy the department of
energy is responsible for developing net
metering rules pursuant to
362a n and we are actually in the middle
of developing those rules um so I would
just note that for the committee as
well so um in a nutshell I guess um it
wasn't entirely clear to the Department
what the intended benefits of this bill
are financially or otherwise and whether
they do outweigh um any of these
aforementioned concerns um but that
being said if the committee does decide
to move forward uh with this bill the
department would be happy to work with
uh the legislature on that and with that
I will be happy to try and answer any
questions okay thank you very much
excellent information appreciate you
sharing that with us questions
representative
Harrington thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking a question I'm just
trying to walk through the scenario a
little bit so I can see if what what
this bill would do so we have um someone
who's already a group so there's
presumably there's a host there that's
producing renewable energy on a larger
scale than the 100 kilowatts or what is
100 kilowatts so they're maybe they're
producing you know 800 Kow or larger and
they s that back to the utility the
excess but they have agreements with
load other load entities that say I want
I'll take credit for so much of this
power and someone else take credit for
so much of this power and presumably
they may or may not enter into a
financial relationship on that
so I would assume they're doing it
because they're going to save money but
that would only make common sense so now
we're going to have a new entity come in
which would be a small customer
generator producing less than 100
kilowatt and then they would become part
of that group so with what they net
meter would that go back to the host and
go out through his accounting uh stuff
and be credited to the load uh entities
that he's got a contract with or would
they continue to net meter as they had
been in the past and just net meter it
out but then when they bought power like
at night they or whenever um they would
buy it from as part of the group that's
what I'm trying to figure out that's a
great question um representative and
it's not really clear how that would
work out one of our one of the other
considerations um was whether these new
um customer generator members how their
load would be attributed to the group is
it if if they're net metering is it is
it the net from that and is it the net
after they're netted through the Tariff
U the alternative tariff in that or is
it just their their total usage um it's
not clear followup followup because my
my issue there is with just kind of what
you're saying it seems as if you could
start out with the group being let's say
800 kilowatt generator and then you
could add I don't know 10 15 100
kilowatt uh net meter to that and so
actually the net metering total would
become more than the total for the for
the original group so I don't know
whether they would be able if they would
but put some of that back through the
for the group and and have load entities
to buy it and some would be just net
metered to the utility it's just doesn't
seem to be any definition of that am I
missing something no I um I would agree
there's probably some clarification that
need to be done and and I think I would
add to that if
um there doesn't seem to be any limiting
language in this in terms of if there's
a customer generator member who's in a
group theoretically there could then be
another that customer generator member
could be a host for other members and
then does it kind of where does that end
to and the complexity is
just so just to clarify what you just
said so you're talking about overlapping
groups correct okay thank you uh
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question
um there's there's a a clarifica a
clarification question would you want
like to take that one
first yes let's take the clarification
question first representative McGee
thank you Mr chair I I have notes here
um that rep representative Corman placed
um for some clarification that under pu
90220 large customer generator means a
customer generator whose facility has a
total maximum generation capacity
greater than 100 KW um alternating
current up to and including one megawatt
so it's
specified what a large generator would
be like it can't be add infin item I
guess um and it also specifies currently
what a sort of what a member is in those
rules pu
90222 a member means a customer of the
same distribution utility as the host
who signs an agreement to be a member of
the group under RSA 362 A9 and who
remains a customer of the same
distribution utility as the host during
its membership to the group and accept
uh as provided in pu
90216 who is not a customer generator so
there's the there's the exemption that
they would like to have
Rewritten
um so they'd like to change the last
Clause to uh pu 90222 reading who is not
a large customer generator yeah
so those are his notes that you you know
he did the research I don't just reading
them Wendy Thomas has a question thank
you um thank you for being here um one
of your points in your testimony is you
said that there are implications for the
utilities for billing and other
accounting systems indicating that that
might be an obstacle um can you tell me
in your discussions have you figured out
is this because they don't have the
current capability to do this or is this
so
um I was in my testimony I was trying to
speculate that um you know since this is
this would require probably new changes
to their billing systems just based on
the accounting that would be required
for it so it's sort of speculation that
it would probably require
new upgrades to those systems um that
would I would I would assume cost have a
cost to them so we could defer that
question to Mr Lata who probably can
followup okay further questions
representative Summers thank you Mr
chairman just a quick question just to
clarify you might have St at the
beginning but um what is the position
the doe has has um where do you stand on
Bill 654 we're neutral on this bill
okay seeing no further questions we want
to thank you for being here to give us
the Department's take on this
legislation final pink guard is for
back good afternoon uh Michael lado
representing ever energy again uh
appreciate the opportunity to testify
before you uh we do have uh concerns
with the bill as written um in the sort
of the first issue is uh we we do agree
with the Department of energy that the
proposed language as written um is
somewhat counter to the original purpose
of group net metering so uh as has been
discussed the idea behind group net
metering is that you would have
customers who are unable to participate
in the net metering program whether
that's a residential customer whose roof
is shaded or facing the wrong way or uh
someone who lives in an apartment
building or we talked a lot about
Condominiums this morning but for
whatever reason they could not site a
distributed generation resource at their
uh at their home or business uh and so
could not participate in group net
metering therefore sorry could not
participate in metering therefore group
net metering was created to allow uh a
large uh net metering installation large
solar installation to share the benefits
of that uh net metering with those
customers who again for whatever reason
their property would not allow them to
participate in net metering um we do
read the bill uh in a similar way that I
think representative Vose and and
representative McGee had a back and
forth on that it would allow customers
small customer generators who
participate in net metering on their own
to also participate in group net
metering uh so again this is a customer
who has solar on their we'll just say
house they are participating in net
metering they are receiving credits uh
for their exports through the net
metering program
and they would also now under this uh be
allowed to participate in group net
metering and receive presumably uh
compensation or or exports uh
compensation from the exports of the
group from the group host um we do have
concerns with that both administratively
as well as uh in terms of the accounting
um I understand just based upon the
testimony today that PO that wasn't the
intent of of the bill sponsor of the
bill uh but from a utility imple
implementation standpoint uh that would
be very hard for us to administer and
provide those credits back to uh uh the
customer generator who is net metered
but also a member of the group uh and so
uh I did uh have conversations with our
team about uh you know billing systems
and administration and um they did
confirm that our billing systems would
not be able to accommodate that as they
are currently structured uh and quite
frankly they're not sure utility billing
systems by and large uh could do it it
would require uh essentially complete
manual intervention for us to do it so
someone would physically be working off
of a spreadsheet taking um uh data out
of our Billing System applying it
through a spreadsheet and then manually
applying it to uh to customer bills
which obviously increases our costs
which would be passed along to customers
but also um you know we always have a
concern that the more manual
intervention that we have the
possibility for for human error uh
exists so th those are the concerns uh
with the bill and happy to answer
questions that the committee may
have okay thank you questions for
eversource repres resentative Harrington
thank you thank you for taking my
question I'm just trying to figure how
this thing would play out and it seems
like there's there's two types of
scenarios the group net metering is
allowed up to a megawatt so say if we
had a group net metering that was close
to a megawatt the small generator uh net
metering is less than 100 megawatts if
kilowatts I'm sorry sorry thank you that
would be a heal big small generator but
um so but this would allow multiple
small generators to join that group so
in effect the net output of that group
when you considered it just as all the
entities put together could be 14 could
be well over a megawatt could be one and
a half megawatts 1.6 megawatts which
sort of would seem to violate the whole
concept of keeping it capit at megawatt
either that or the some of the small
generators that join once they hit the
one megawatt level would then revert
back to becoming individual net meters
and so they wouldn't affect double dip I
don't see I think this's I don't see
another option so I I I would interpret
it differently which is um the group
host uh and and you know everyone who is
not uh a municipal host is allowed to
net meter up to one megawatt the
differential between the small customer
generator under 100kw and the large
customer generator is financial uh it's
it's what um uh compensation they get
from the utility uh so the large
customer generator only gets the supply
rate versus the small customer generator
gets um portions of uh transmission and
distribution so
as I think we would look at it um it the
small customer generator who was
participating in a group would not be
additive to the group host you have a
group host they have a facility that
operates up to a certain um kilowatt or
or megawatt level uh and they are
sharing the benefits of their exports
with the members of their group this
would add to it that the members of
their group could have their own
solar uh and be participating as a and
separately be um part of the net
metering program but I I don't think
what it would be additive to the group
host because that's uh facility specific
so
yeah followup rep followup before you do
that though representative McGee I'd
remind you that um you need to get my
attention and permission before you
speak
so it's just so I get this clear what
you're saying is that once that one
megawatt cap was reached whether it was
by the group host by itself or with the
group host with the addition of some new
small generators that would be the
maximum any further small generators
that were in the in that added to that
group would basically they wouldn't be
there I mean they would act as regular
net meter as because they couldn't
exceed the one megawatt Gap
so my reading of it is is that the small
G Customer generators are participating
as members not as a component of the
host and so therefore their uh the size
of their solar would not be added to the
host size so it wouldn't be you have a
host it's a um you know a a a certain
number and then you you would add stack
on top of that the small customer
generators they would only be the small
customer generators under the bill would
only be participating as takers not um
producers they would still get um
compensation under net metering for
their experts but that would be separate
and distinct from uh for the purposes of
Arrangement and is it also not true that
the way group net metering is structured
the the total load for the host the
group net host has to match the load
that's accepted by the members of the
group at the end of the year otherwise
the group host uh has to Forfeit some of
his net metering benefits is that
correct so so that's that is correct
that the the host Arrangement has to
account for all of the their exports and
again if you think about having small
customers small customer generators
excuse me being part of that group host
Arrangement their load is going to be
variable and that's where the challenges
with the accounting come in you know can
we account for um and right now the onus
is on the group host to account for all
of their export and they make that
certification to to the Department of
energy now we have customer generators
who would be part small customer
generators who would be participating
and obviously there's variability in
their load and Export that could impact
those host
arrangements so if I understood you
correctly in addition to this being a
billing challenge for a utility this
would also be a an accounting challenge
for the Department of energy trying to
manage these
groups and account for
their uh imports and exports to their
group members yeah which have to be Tred
up at the end of the year right yeah I I
believe the I heard the department of
energy testify concerns about the
accounting okay thank you further
questions representative reels thank you
Mr chairman I um I I genuinely want to
ask you if I
was correct earlier when
I told everyone here that the in a group
net
metering
situation the compensation that the
group
members may
get uh comes
from the group
host and is
is not not
provided by the utility is that correct
so a group host is compensated by the
utility for their exports yes uh they
can either we can either write them a
check uh or we can do on bill crediting
for the members of their group so I I
think the point that you're making that
if I may large larger generator um and I
elect to participate in net metering I'm
going to receive compensation if I'm a
the same generator and I elect to uh be
a group host and now we're assigning the
values to um to the members of that
group it doesn't really change the
initial level of compensation you're
still would have been compensated for
your exports that I I agree with
okay thank you
okay seeing no further questions I want
to thank you for testifying here and I
want to uh because I have no more pink
cards I want to close the public hearing
on House Bill 654
FN and immediately turn
to uh House Bill
541 establishing a committee to study
energy and Telecommunications
infrastructure Sur
survivability and resiliency
so I am going to open that public
hearing and I have no pink cards at the
moment but I
anticipate that the bill sponsor who is
uh standing right before the table is
going to be available to introduce this
legislation so I'm going to call
on representative McFarland to introduce
House Bill
541 that's a good guess Michael in the
pink should be working its way around to
you uh good morning Mr chairman
honorable members of committee I'm
representative Donald McFarland from
Orange I thank you for the opportunity
to introduce House Bill 541 this
testimony represents My Views and the
views and interests of my constituents
in graft and 18 my testimony is not made
on behalf of any private employer nor
should it be construed to represent the
views of any of my
employers House Bill 541 before you uh
proposes the establishment of a
committee to study the
survivability and the resiliency of New
Hampshire's energy and
Telecommunications
infrastructure and I I'm not going to
insult your intelligence by reading out
the bill I know you can can read what's
in there so let me tell you a little bit
about why I'm putting this before the
committee uh recent disclosures have
highlighted significant nation state
physical and cyber threats targeting our
critical infrastructure Nationwide New
Hampshire is not immune to those risks
and I I'll make a few comments about the
the bill itself and the committee that
it seeks to establish in a second but
let me give you some context around that
there's been a raft of commentary in the
media uh such as this quote I was I was
looking at a number of quotes and a
number of Articles earlier today in
preparation for this and one guy said we
are in a new Cold War the PRC as the
enemy and we must treat them as such Why
are we seeing those quotes made if we
look to the opinion of some experts who
are in a position to know I would cite
an newberger and I don't regard this by
the way as a partisan bill I hope that
none of you does uh an if you're not
familiar with who she is served as the
deputy National Security adviser for
cyber and emerging Technologies in the
Biden Administration uh and assumed that
role in 2021 having a distinguished
career in some of our security agencies
and she resigned from that position in
the last month nevertheless in December
she explained that once Chinese hackers
had infiltrated our telecommunications
network uh networks in in a recent
breach which I'll come back to uh they
had achieved Broad and full access to
our citizens data allowing them to
geolocate millions of individuals and
record phone calls at will I'm referring
to a breach that has been well
publicized since September
uh in the Wall Street Journal and in
other media uh referred to as salt
typhoon uh this breach was publicly
acknowledged by the FBI in November and
if you look at the September article in
the Wall Street Journal uh I will quote
from that very briefly if I may last
week us officials said they had
disrupted a network of more than 200,000
routers cameras and other Internet
connected consumer devices that served
as an entry point into US Network works
for a china-based hacking group called
flax typhoon and in January Federal
officials disrupted Vault typhoon yet
another China link campaign that has
sought to quietly infiltrate a swath of
us critical infrastructure the Cyber
threat posed by the Chinese government
is massive said Christopher Ray the
FBI's director speaking earlier this
year at a security conference in Germany
China's hacking program is larger than
that of every other major Nation
combined US security officials allege
that Beijing has tried and at times
succeeded in borrowing deep into US
critical infrastructure networks ranging
from water treatment systems to airports
and oil and gas pipelines now what I
just read to you from that September
article was not about the salt typhoon
breach it was about the history that we
have seen in recent months uh of other
activity certainly we've seen activity
from other state actors uh and we've
seen activity from uh criminals for the
usual purposes that they pursue things
but what we're seeing here uh does in
fact represent a sea change at the end
of last year the executive director of
us cyber command had this to say let's
not hide he said the simple fact that we
have uncovered and exposed multiple
People's Republic of China Global cyber
operations and he went on to explain
that we've seen a shift from PRC cyber
operations targeting our defense
industrial base and conducting large
scale intellect ual property theft to a
new modus operandi about which he
concluded the PRC is executing a global
cyber campaign targeting
telecommunications Cloud critical
infrastructure and our defense industry
to gain a military and technological
advantage in preparation for times of
Crisis or conflict with the us and our
allies it's important to step back from
Individual incidents and understand the
gravity of the combined events and so I
I think I've uh given you some
indications as to why I consider this to
be an important bill I'm happy to follow
up with the committee and share articles
and other information with you but back
to the the commit the bill itself uh I
I'm sure that you understand the
economic and Public Safety implications
of disruptions to our energy and
Telecommunications infrastructure and I
submit to you that there are also
significant National Defense
implications and when you take that uh
into consideration uh with the the other
Uh current events that we have observed
uh I believe you will understand why
this committee is warranted as to the
structure of the committee I could
readily be persuaded that this should in
fact be a study commission not a study
committee as many of you will appreciate
uh with the back and forth with OS over
the holidays and and their uh volume of
work I was not able to achieve precisely
the draft that I might have sought I
defer to the committee as to the best
way to move forward with the bill uh but
I would say that by supporting this we
take a significant step towards securing
our state's critical infrastructure and
I urge the committee to favorably
consider this bill and recommend its
passage thank you for your time and
questions okay thank you for introducing
this legislation could you uh just give
us a quick uh idea of your background I
believe you have a cyber security
background that is true Mr chairman I
have uh spent a great many years of my
life focused on telecommunications and
cyber security and information
technology in one way or another I I uh
um I just turned 50 recently and I can
tell you that I have over 40 years
playing around with uh uh telecoms and
cyber um some of which were on my own
dime as a kid operating a bulletin board
and many of which have been more
recently uh being paid to do that work
uh how however as I said at the start uh
I'm not here on behalf of any of my
employers I'm here uh representing my my
passion and my interest in securing our
nation and making sure that uh we are
giving proper attention to what I think
is an important concern I know it's a
concern that is something that we expect
to see addressed in Washington DC um but
I do also think that it is a concern
that appropriately should be the subject
I guess what I was trying to establish
is that since this is
a a
vocational uh you have the vocational
background to understand the seriousness
threats is that what prompted you to
submit this leg legislation you think
there is some some significant threat
out there that we should be looking at
I I'll answer that in two ways Mr
chairman I think first of all that um
the words that I quoted from uh an no
Berger and from uh the the executive
director of us cyber command who's
actually a guy called Morgan adamsky are
two of many that I could have quoted
from who are far better placed than I am
to aine on the immediacy of the threat
and the Strategic importance of the
threat what what I can comment on is
that this is something that we should be
prepared for and when I think about our
technology policy and our energy policy
here in New Hampshire I am as you've
heard me testify on other bills I am
keenly interested in achieving cheap and
reliable energy but as I present this
bill to you I suggest to you that
reliability is not the only concern and
we should be keenly interested in
whether or not we are creating a grid
and creating uh the the utility
infrastructure that is needed for it to
be survivable and resilient in the event
of
conflict okay let's uh have some
questions from representative Harrington
first um you know reading your bill I
understand that you've uh concisely put
out that there a huge problem we're
dealing with I just I wonder what is
that a group of uh New Hampshire State
reps and a couple of other people going
to do to address this hugely complicated
and you know phenomena that's well well
outside the realm of New Hampshire I
mean I don't see that we're going to be
able to produce anything
usable it's a great question
representative and I think that uh
that's part of the reason I was alluding
to maybe this should be a commission not
a committee I think that this is a topic
that we should be monitoring on an
ongoing basis and uh we should be
staying AB breast of uh developments in
Washington as well as uh in the Press um
I do believe that state and local
government has a role to play in the
response and to that extent I think it's
warranted for um this legislature to be
aware of these issues and to monitor
them and to consider uh what what policy
actions or other um actions we may want
to recommend um I don't however think to
your point that this is something that
we're going to be able to uh do like a
oneandone look at later in the year and
then close the committee and be done
with it for the foreseeable
future representative McGee thank you Mr
chair and thank you representative
mcfallen for being here again um my
question is along the same lines as
representative Harrington's because as I
look at how the bill is actually written
um I think the makeup is fairly narrow
for such a broad topic but I also see
the turnaround time oftentimes these
bills are not signed into law until June
and then if you have 45 minutes to have
your first meeting you're talking July
and the report is due not even four
months later on a huge topic so I was
just
wondering whether you would consider
modifying this because um if it does
need serious consideration and potential
even ongoing
consideration um it needs a begin date
and maybe even an end date and also uh
some real thought around how long it
would take for us to get anything that's
really worthwhile or
right representative Summers has a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative McFarland for taking
my question I appreciate that you or
have a background in in cyber security
and I'm very interested in have
background as well um this bill this
commission or committee excuse me would
something would take effect as I know
that uh there's an issue with Huawei
wireless access points for example B all
the way down I25 right by our Minuteman
silos Southwest um would this study is
something like as if a the government
purchasing it on the cheap WWE let's say
for example Huawei Wi-Fi devices by sebr
something like that would that would
that be covered with this committee so I
think the short answer to your question
representative is yes uh it certainly
could fall within the purview of the
committee I will say to you by way of
example um and I I assure you I don't
have any shares in the Wall Street
Journal but but I will cite them again
for no better reason than that's what I
was looking at earlier uh in December uh
in a Wall Street Journal article um it
was talking about a a slightly different
problem than the Huawei uh problem it
was talking about some consumer routers
it was talking about Soho routers in in
your uh houses and and and you know your
homes and offices uh and it said the
defense department earlier this year
opened an investigation into National
Security vulnerabilities in Chinese
routers according to people familiar
with the matter uh the house select
committee on the Chinese Communist party
in August urged the Commerce Secretary
to investigate TP Link because it
presents an unusual degree of
vulnerabilities um and I could go on but
I I the point that I'm making there is I
think we know that there is a supply
chain concern that is Broad and um I
I've seen commentary around for example
the attempt by uh HP and and Juniper
emerge and some commentary around that
and and uh Huawei and look I I don't
want to um give you my thoughts on that
I think it's tangential to the issue at
hand but what isn't tangential to the
issue at hand is that the more that we
create this supply chain risk uh into
are not just uh generating uh plant and
and grid but even right into people's
houses uh and meters and and all these
end points um and I know we' have an
interest in this committee on you know
things like solar that are heavily
distributed and there's a lot of
technology in that you know there's all
kinds of uh I I don't want to use the
word unforeseen because I think there
are some of us who who certainly have
talked about these risks for a long time
but there are there are ramifications
that uh need to be thought about
elements next um representative Swanson
has a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you for your time representative
McFarland uh I do not follow nearly as
closely uh probably the media that you
have and but I am aware I believe that
not only China but other nation state
actors are interested in getting into
these places so I I share your concerns
as in be afraid be very afraid kind of a
thing and so but my question is it this
U maybe a two-prong question the scope
seems very large and there seems to be a
need to accomplish this that you would
have to have some very knowledgeable
people investigate the installation of
the equipment in each of these centers
or you know these these nodes in this
Communications Network as well as what's
provided and I'm glad that you did not
include all residential installations
and so forth uh but uh I'm I'm trying to
gather is was it in your intent that is
that this is what a commission would do
is just contact
every uh facility or installation or a
business as far as how they their it
infrastructure is set up and then advise
the state about the vulnerabilities they
have I should think that for example
there's uh I think the federal
government has something called sisa
that provides advisories to uh anyone
with an IT infrastructure and anybody
that's a large organization is going to
have its own it department just as you
know as the state does so uh what added
value would you provide in addition to
what kind of invas or um I I wouldn't
say Invasion but uh information that you
would be gathering for from these
organizations to report
on thank you so I I think there's quite
a few questions wrapped up in there so
apologies if I don't get all of them and
feel free to tell me I missed something
um what I would say first of all is I I
don't want anyone to come away from this
thinking that um I I am uh trying to
paint a a picture of of uh this being
being a a terrible circumstance um what
I am trying to do is focus on
preparedness right I have great
confidence in our current Administration
and its ability to uh not um end up with
you know bringing us into to war and and
creating other uh adverse circumstances
in the near future and I think that
gives us a period of time in which we
can focus sensibly on whether there is
something to to be done here and what
that is to be done to your point about
the different threat actors you're
absolutely right we see a number of
different uh actors including a number
of different nation states such as Iran
such as Russia um such as North Korea
who continue to act uh in in ways that
are detrimental to our interests um I
think we could have an interesting
debate around whether we've seen the
same sea change from any of those uh
actors that we have seen in the case of
china that I was just citing um but
whether or not that is true if we do the
work for one it should be adequate unto
all um and so I think to your question
you know I think you asked me what I
plan on doing uh in this committee look
I this is not about me this is not about
any one person um this is about whether
we as a state as we're in other bills
before this committee setting our energy
policy and
influencing the private sector that you
talk about in how they plan on working
within the state uh it's about making
sure that we are giving due
consideration not only to the absolute
economic efficiency of Our Generation uh
and grid infrastructure and
Telecommunications infrastructure but
whether we are also contemplating
whether what what is being achieved
there uh is focusing adequately on all
of the the elements that you spoke about
that end up creating a survivable and
resilient infrastructure and so when I
look at the amount of of money that is
spent by some of the the companies in
the energy sector and in the
telecommunication sector on it security
and I compare that to other Industries
um I I'm not prepared with specific
numbers before this committee but I can
tell you that I I I understand there to
discrepancy representative Howard you
have a
question yes thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question so I
was just curious because I know that
we've talked a lot about foreign actors
but would this committee or commission
look at the weatherization uh of this
type of infrastructure weatherization
you said yes I I mean I I can't off the
top of my head see how that would be
Jermaine okay all right thank you
Vice chair Thomas has a question thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question so um I'm not sure I'm asking
the question um obviously this is an
important
concern Nationwide and I do mean
Nationwide so is your bill um supposing
or or proposing that right now the state
is not looking into any potential
threats of cyber secur whatsoever and
there's nobody out there that's looking
into it and secondly uh does not the
state uh would not the state be
coordinating with the Department of uh
Homeland Security on because these
issues are widespread right wouldn't
they be receiving warnings on these
things yeah great questions I I think
first of all of course I'm not saying
that we are not already doing a great
deal in this direction um what I am
saying is that uh we have seen uh in
some of those events that I was alluding
to uh we have
seen a change in behavior of some of
these thread actors that
uh plenty of folks consider meaningful
in the ways that I outlined and
therefore I think in addition to the
status quo uh which includes as you say
uh activity by the DHS and activity by
our state cyber security committee and
so forth um I think that it is incumbent
upon this committee to take account of
uh these factors in as I was alluding to
in my answer to representative Swanson
uh in how we attend to uh for example
energy policy and uh policy with the the
telecommunications companies in the
state and what I see is I see that we
have uh some companies represented in
our state serving our citizens who are
large entities who are going to be well
tied in to um the the activities at the
national level and then we have some
smaller uh entities that uh are likely
able to be you know deriving benefit
from uh what we might do at the state
level to support them uh and and I think
in either case I come back to my my
answer of are we in any legislation that
we
contemplate are we making making sure to
preference survivability and and
reliability followup thank you for for
the followup so there so um are you
implying that this committee or
commission
would say for instance be calling in the
Department of Homeland Security and the
state cyber security people to have them
come down and tell you tell the
committee what's going on and and to be
advised of of any new threats coming so
that you could uh have seminars or or
something like that is is that what
you're implying with this I I think let
me answer that question broadly if I may
um because I I I'll interpret that
question as what do you think that the
Practical work of the committee would
be um and and I don't presume to answer
that wholly but I will say that I think
it is appropr rate to see whether or not
the utility companies that are the the
key utility companies serving our state
uh are themselves well prepared uh and
what their point of view is around these
issues and depending upon the responses
that we might receive from each of them
it would then inform I think in a
meaningful way the committee as to what
else and from whom else it sought to
take testimony but I certainly agree
that there are um experts that it would
be useful to seek testimony from in
committee representative Wendy
Thomas thank you Mr chair um I actually
have two questions but I'll do it one at
a time um we're currently seeing a large
cyber security breach in DC so would
this committee you keep talking about
Chinese and other states would this
domestic so I I think your question
again is is in some ways similar to
representative Swanson's question about
are there multiple thread actors I think
we all understand that there are
different people doing different things
and some of them may be um you know a
kid in in the the basement of their
parents' house and others may be uh
10,000 um well funded uh agents in a
building in Beijing um But whichever of
those you are or anywhere in between
what I would hope is that we give due
consideration to is there anything that
that we ought to consider and that we
ought to do in order to protect uh and
prepare our state and the answer to that
by the way might be no right we may very
well find to representative Thomas's
question that we believe that this is
already well attended to in other ways
in other places I do think however that
if we decide uh as an output of this
committee that there is specific policy
recommendations to be made that those
recommendations should be
recommendations that help us defend
against all enemies and uh do so you
know all all serious enemies that we
consider to be a serious threat and that
do so without regard to any one um uh
particular uh source and the reason I
say that is not simply what we just laid
out that there are multiple threat
actors out there it's also that it's not
adequate to say we are defending
against uh a threat that is is from one
known location we we have you know
you're broadening the question and
talking about what's going on in DC I'll
talk about what's going on in the nation
we have a bunch of uh immigrants
uh in this nation who are here legally
and who we are very happy to see here
and I I am one of those who's proud and
and delighted to be a US citizen now we
also have seen a bunch of illegal
immigration coming across the border and
there are those who would assert that
there's pre-staging of individuals in
this country who can take action in the
Physical Realm so I I think when you ask
me how should we be cont lating this and
what should the output be yes it should
be something that is not focused on any
one geographical region followup follow
up um so thank you for that answer um
bills are always put forward with an
intention of some kind of an
outcome where is this committee heading
and can you give me some specific
examples of legislation that may come
out of this
committee I I would prefer not to only
because because I think that I don't
want to prejudge I think the whole point
of having a committee is to hear
testimony and form an objective
Viewpoint and I would hate to color that
with my personal opinion I think the
most important thing this committee
could do is solicit uh testimony from
experts as I mentioned earlier thank you
representative
Bernardi thank you chair uh so you've uh
articulated many cyber security threats
but as I read the bill it's much broader
and potentially uh uh investigation of
threats to the grid and its need for
hardening could be con considered by
this committee do I have that right or
have I misgauged the scope no I I think
you're exactly right representative and
what was going through my mind when I
wrote that language uh was that there is
a physical element as I was alluding to
with representative Thomas there is a pH
physical element to these threats we
have seen I think um I may get this
wrong I think it was North Carolina we
saw in the last year or two where there
was attacks on uh some of the
substations uh we've seen the same in
California um and we know that the lead
time for for example a new Transformer
uh if it's one of these complicated
distribution
Transformers at one point I was seeing
it advertised as two three maybe 5 years
I believe it to be more in the order of
decade or more uh for the lead time for
some of these big transformers when you
look at that when you look at the uh the
physical protection of of a few chain
link fences that we have around some of
those important facilities and you look
at the the ways in which a threat actor
would think about taking action uh I
think you know as I I alluded to earlier
the question of are we spending the
right proportion of revenues on physical
and cyber security and and yes I'm
putting physical in the front there uh
sir representative schneller has a
question thank you chairman Vos and
thank you for your testimony
representative McFarland uh I've heard
some things a little bit specific like
you you did mention H Packard Enterprise
Juniper and then sort of begged off of
that as a subject um and then this
legislation appears to be more broadly
oriented
I'm just wondering is this something
that requires
leadership uh and a role more from the
executive branch than it should and uh
should be from the
legislature I would just say to you as I
mentioned to the committee upfront that
the particular form if there is you know
a recommendation for passage here the
particular form of of what it is that we
put into place is something that I defer
to your joint expertise as to what makes
the most
sense thank
you okay seeing no further questions I
want to thank you for introducing this
legislation and I'll call up Michael
Lana from ever Source thank you Mr
perspective afternoon uh thank you again
Michael Lata representing eversource
energy um I just want to start off by
saying I I very much appreciate uh the
sponsor's goal and his eloquent
testimony uh introducing uh the bill I
obviously eversource could not agree
more uh about the critical nature of
securing uh the transmission and
Distribution Systems that we operate uh
it is a um uh significant issue it is is
uh you know the sponsor is correct to
point out the significant and consistent
threats that that infrastructure faces
on a daily hourly minute by minute basis
um I did want to just testify uh because
I don't want the committee um or or the
sponsor quite frankly to be left with
the impression that there is a
regulatory Gap uh that the utility and I
can only speak for uh eversource
obviously but uh that electric
distribution and transmission uh
utilities um there isn't adequate
oversight or coordination with state and
federal uh agencies and so I just
thought it might be helpful just to take
off a few of the agencies that have
regulatory oversight uh in this area and
that we have to coordinate uh this is
not a comprehensive list um but they do
include the Federal Energy Regulatory
Commission the cyber security or FK the
cyber C security infrastructure Security
Agency or sisa the North American
Electric reliability Corporation or nerk
ISO New England which I know this
committee is very well familiar with the
National Association of regulatory
utility uh Commissioners or nuk uh the
New Hampshire Department of energy
enforcement division the New Hampshire
Homeland Security and Emergency
Management um Department the Public
Utilities Commission of New Hampshire as
well as state and federal law
enforcement uh agencies uh these are all
different state federal agencies that uh
either promate rules set guidelines or
we have to share confidential
information with them regarding our
cyber security or physical security
planning uh and that's both for the
transmission and the distribution
infrastructure uh I will say um we look
at this from a number of different uh
perspectives not just the operational
perspective of the security at during uh
communic grid communication and grid
operations but also we look very
carefully at our supply chains and the
equipment and the origin of that
equipment uh that actually gets put into
uh our systems um the the
only note uh of concern I would point
out is just um you know just trying to
think through the um operations of this
legislative committee and um what we can
share uh with the public and what we can
share with uh a legislative committee uh
I obviously mentioned a lot of different
state and federal agencies uh a lot of
that planning a lot of that work is
provided on a confidential basis and is
obviously um a matter of of state and
federal security so uh with that I'd be
happy to answer uh whatever questions I
can but again I I just do want to point
out that um very much in agreement with
the SP sponsor's goal and intent and I
think he uh did a very good job
face Vice chair Thomas thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking me a
question um I I agree with both parties
um my question is you named off a lot of
agencies just then and I'm sure that
wasn't all of them do you believe that
this
legislation would be able
to
determine or
evaluate um if these agencies are
all accurately talking to each other for
a common me in other words are they all
working together for a common message so
this that committee would be able to
understand if anything else needs to be
done or not or would we be mired in a
lot of different agencies with a lot of
different rules that may not may or may
not talk to each other as we've seen
happen in the
past I think that's an excellent
question um you know obviously we look
at it through the lens of electric uh
infrastructure the uh the legislation is
written more broadly than that uh
there's natural gas infrastructure
there's telecommunications
infrastructure um there's generation uh
electric generation infrastructure that
again eversource doesn't have have a
window into um I think it would be very
difficult for any agency or any
commission or committee um
to be able to do an evaluation of each
different state and federal agency's
role and determine if there were gaps in
the
um I I think you
would need these agencies to participate
uh and I don't know what the likelihood
of that is again we you know we would be
certainly uh responsive to um uh If This
Were to pass uh but it's it's a
significant undertaking as you might
imagine representative Summers has a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question going off off
would you would you think would you have
to believe that the uh bill would this
be able to create a form of security for
at least Le legislators of since this is
the science tech technology and energy
committee to be able to grasp understand
where our electrical grids security
stance is where our our state's um
Information Technology stance security
stance is would we be able to collect
that do you believe this bill would
allow us to maybe a secure in a secure
setting be able to understand and grasp
what the security is of our
infrastructure
um I I think this if passed this
commission would allow an opportunity
for members of the legislature to ask
questions of
um different state agencies and
different uh private entities like
utilities or Telecommunications
companies uh
to uh provide information in a more
General sense around planning and
oversight um but I I think it would be I
I don't think we could
provide um sensitive materials on what
the substance of those plans are in a
meaningful
way representative Wendy Thomas thank
you Mr chair um I have similar concerns
that have been already raised um you
specifically said um that that you have
confidential plans um committee meetings
are open to the public and they're taped
so so that would we couldn't discuss any
confidential plans but my my question is
does unitel have a dedicated person or
Department uh I'm sorry eversource um
that sorry um that regularly meets to
address um these issues and do all of
the utilities to the best of your
knowledge have a similar Counterpoint
person or Department yes we we uh at
eversource
have departments plural that are
responsible for cyber security uh
Information Technology physical security
and those extend to you know the
security of our meters uh the compliance
of those the communications of those
meters um uh all the way through our
operations Department if you think you
this committee has heard presentations
from me and other Utilities in the past
about grid Automation and our SK systems
and the communications that we have um
throughout our electric and trans
distribution and transmission systems so
there are multiple departments that are
engaged in reviewing all of uh the
security of all of those and making sure
that it is compliant with our cyber
security plans as well as all the
various agencies that I had mentioned
again all the way down through our
supply chain and where we are sourcing
materials from so um it is an extremely
rigorous program n not program but
programs uh and I feel fairly confident
not that I can speak for any other
utility that uh they have similar uh
you okay seeing no further questions I
want to thank you for your testimony and
I'm going to close the public hearing on
House Bill
541 next we're going to open a public
hearing on Senate Bill 4 and I'm going
to turn the gavel over
you have his card do you have his card
no no give me
one
one welcome uh chairman Vose uh you will
be introducing sb4 relative to
commercial property assessed clean
energy and resiliency otherwise known as
C Pacer um you're on thank you Mr Vice
chair good afternoon members of the
committee for the record representative
Michael Vose representing Rockingham
District
Five so I'm here to introduce on behalf
of the senate senate Bill four this is
identical to the C Pacer bill that we
heard in this committee last Tuesday a
week from
today there are two changes to this bill
compared to the one we heard last week
and Mr key Wallace from the business
Finance Authority will refresh our
memory as to what those two changes are
I didn't write them down so I'm not 100%
certain but um when we heard a
description of what those changes would
be last week we both we all agreed I
think that those changes were good ones
and made the bill even
better so what the Senate did with this
bill is they passed it out of committee
then they passed it through the entire
Senate sent it over here to us and what
the house leadership has asked us to do
is to pass this Senate Bill hold on to
our house bill until this Senate Bill
comes before the full house if it pass
is the Full House then we can um it'll
go to the governor's desk and we can
dispose of the house bill as this bill
will take its
place so with that bill introduction I'm
going to step aside and let Mr key
Wallace answer any questions that you
might have about the Bill thank you
thank you chairman vs there be no
questions I'll call on Mr James key
Wallace
welcome Mr James K walles thank you very
much Mr uh Vice chair um um for the
record James key Wallace executive
director of the New Hampshire business
Finance Authority I'm a little bit more
uh stuffy in my nose than I was here
last week I apologize um so um if I
sound a little stuffy that's just the
way it is but I hope we didn't give you
something I don't think so I think was
courtesy of my uh cute and cuddly
5-year-old kindergarten son so um so uh
this bill as chairman Vose correctly
pointed out differs in two small ways
from the bill we heard testimony on last
week perhaps I'd like to start just by
identifying what those are to refresh
the committee and then after that I'm
happy to repeat my testimony or as the
committee prefers just take questions
that you may have had since now and then
so so the first change from the house
sponsored bill is at the top of page
five the sentence starting on line
one you can see here the sentence in s
sp4 reads enter into agreements with
owners of eligible property in which the
owners have consented there was an extra
apostrophe that was confusing in the
previous bill um sounds minor but it it
actually confuses how many of the owners
are needed to provide consent to
encumber the property this says well
they all do which makes sense so that's
change
one change two is on the next page on
page
six it's the sentences beginning at the
very end of line 26 and finishing on
line
28 the existing language in the house
bill didn't explicitly refer to the
statute in
91a about confidential commercial and
financial information which existing BFA
loan applications are defined as so this
is consistent with the language to
protect applicants personal financial
statements the business's Trade Secrets
their budgets all of those things that
people don't want to just have all out
there for anyone to see when they apply
for a loan so that clarifies exactly
what that's pointing to in
91a those are the two changes Mr
chairman thank you this is a weird
question I know but if you look at the
very bottom of page 6 line
37 what is that bracket
semicolon there do you know what that is
that a mistake or does that have some
meeting
it appears to me to be the first
character of The Struck Provisions which
continue on the next page page seven
okay y yep okay thank you that is a
weird yeah yeah absolutely that's called
a hanging something yeah okay thank you
yeah further questions representative
Wendy Thomas thank you Mr chair um I
took this current bill and I compared it
Page by page with the previous one and I
just want to confirm that it is exactly
the same bill save those two edits would
you not would you agree is that a
correct assessment yes that's my
assessment thank
you further questions representative
Harrington yeah let me first by saying I
wasn't here last week I couldn't make
the hearing so I'm a little I've been
trying to read this bill and make sense
of it and as you can imagine it is
incredibly complicated but I'm trying to
find out
if a couple of basic things about it is
this then going to allow towns to
finance uh qualified projects for
renewable energy whatever for private
houses so great question representative
so um so by way of background New
Hampshire has an existing
cace legislation in place already and I
think work started in the legislature
almost 15 years ago um with the first
version of that bill no cpce loans have
been made um so this bill is an attempt
to remedy the deficits in the various
statutory versions over the
years so cace is a private loan from a
private lender to a privately owned
commercial property for the purposes of
primarily energy
improvements and what is unique about a
cace loan is that instead of writing
your check to your bank which they
probably also will have a bank um each
month for your loan payment you pay the
cpce loan through a special assessment
on your Municipal tax bill it's not in
lie of the existing taxes that get paid
it doesn't uh jump ahead of the town's
taxes or the bank's existing loan um
it's just the way the billing is done
and that actually creates some you
unique mechanisms for the cace lenders
which are all private lenders including
Banks and other other folks where the
loan because it's a tax assessment we we
say it sticks with the property so if
you owned a building and you were like I
want to make some energy improvements
save some money you sell the building
you pay off your bank but the cace loan
is inherited by whoever buys your
building you know full disclosure it's
consent like they all everyone knows um
and and that way you can make those
improvements without having to be like
ah geez if I don't own this building for
a decade I'm not going to
see the ROI on this investment so I'm
just not going to do it this lets the
debt related to the energy Improvement
just get paid over time regardless of
whoever owns the building follow up
follow up but there's no liability on
the part of the municipality whatsoever
and in fact if I read this correctly
whatever administrative cost they have
from collecting this money they get to
charge whatever this Authority is and
get paid their money get reimbursed yes
representative both of those are correct
no liability for the state or any town
uh this is an opt-in program so towns
can choose to adopt it if they want it's
still private loans um most towns elect
if so we looked at states that do cpce
around the country there's about 20
something of
them the town has the option to do the
billing themselves if they want to incur
the cost and get reimbursed or the costs
can be done via like your your loan like
when you make your mortgage payment on
your house there's an escrow line for
your property taxes and insurance same
thing with cpay they you just you just
make your payment the lender is the one
putting all the checks in the right
me okay representative Swanson has a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you very much uh I uh attended the cpce
discussion on the other Bill last week
and uh this very intriguing Financial
instrument just a couple of uh of
curiosity uh related questions one is uh
so I get my tax bill twice a year but if
I get a loan on the house I pay once a
month so uh is it I mean are these
structured so that they can accept the
payments twice a year or Sammy
anel so because it's a private loan from
the cace provider really the payment
schedule can be structured however they
and the borrower want it to be um you
know typically you see monthly because
these are viewed really as I don't want
to say conventional loans but mostly
conventional loans that just happen to
be build through the tax system because
of the benefits the Lend enjoys from a
security perspective so cpce borrowers
are they're paying their loan every
month um even if the assessment isn't
due till every six months but usually
it's due every month they pay every
month well thank you for your answer
followup followup uh just
uh similar to that uh what is the
typical duration how many years are
these loans made for that's a great
question so cpce is designed to try and
stretch the repayment of the financing
out enough that whatever Improvement
you're doing to your property is cash
flow positive right that's the whole
idea make the property more profitable
and save energy so the length of these
loans is defined by the the lender
providing the loan and they
generally make that definition based on
the nature of the Improvement
so if it's a easy really high Roi
project you might see a shorter loan
because the savings are great and you
know you can have a fiveyear loan for
example some loans are 20-year loans
right some are even longer um so it
really just matches whatever the
Improvement is thank you for your answer
thank you Mr
Chair by chair Thomas thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you for taking my
question and uh if I was going to
explain this back to my town I need to
ask this question for one U at least
from my point of view many uh property
taxes are combined with your mortgage
payments through your mortgage e so you
know they uh they the person holding
your mortgage pays monthly into the
taxes and the mortgages as well or puts
it into a scroll how how is that handled
if the the lender wants to be paid
monthly does the mortgage Holder have to
make those individual payments to the
cace
lender thank you representative uh
typically that's the way it's done um
it's designed to try and be as kind of
easy on people as possible um so the
money has to get to the cpce lender
right not the town because it's not the
town who's owed the money it's the the
person providing the loan um some cpce
lenders just say you can write me a
check you know most folks say do it
exactly as you described pay your
mortgage your escrow amount is this and
then that amount gets divied out to the
cpce lender to your Municipal tax
obligations your insurance company all
that
stuff uh representative Harrington has
another
question yeah I'm looking at this uh I
guess it's kind of two-part so I'll ask
both of them uh the authority that this
creates has that already been created
you said there was no loans but and it
seems to be anticipated expenses for the
administration of the program should be
borne by the owners of eligible
properties participating so whatever
cost are associated with this Authority
are going to be included in part of the
loan repayments is that correct uh yes
representative so the authority is
referencing us at the business Finance
Authority and the statute requires that
the users of the program The Borrowers
and the lenders pay for the cost of
administering the program okay followup
follow up well you can go out and get a
loan for something if it's a worthwhile
project you want to put solar panels on
your house uh if you what is the perp
why do we need this extra Authority that
obviously brings in more bureaucracy
more cost administrative all sorts of
administrative costs why why do we have
to do this for alone we don't we don't
don't say oh you can go get a loan to
get a higher mileage car so you can pay
for it through your uh property taxes or
your or your tax assessment on your car
I just don't understand why do we need
this what is it what's what's the
benefit yeah that's a great a great
question so uh two parts to that so
there's no new Authority being creative
like the BF the BFA already exists we
would run this program with no
administrative expenses or any EXP
expenses out of pocket expenses we would
have get passed on to the the users of
the program that's the BFA is a
self-funded entity that doesn't use any
uh State
funds um so but you're right so like
what's the point of cace can't you just
get a loan you know when you when you
need it um as it turns out the answer is
only sometimes um a lot of energy
improvements don't really add physical
kind of value that you can liquidate
right like you know Banks want hard
collateral to say if I lend you this
money it doesn't work out I'm going to
sell this asset and get paid back you
can't really do that when you're adding
insulation in the walls or you know more
efficient Windows because you really
can't separate the improvements to the
building from the the building and so
banks are constrained and what they can
do they might say well this makes sense
from a cash flow perspective but it
doesn't make sense from a collateral
perspective so I can't make the
loan cace
lenders address that problem by using
this tax repayment mechanism because the
existence of this assessment the special
tax assessment means as long as
someone's in the building could be the
next owner or the owner after that those
that person will pick up and make the
monthly cace loans so they know they'll
get paid eventually um so it's just a
way to secure their cash
flow lending separate from the
collateral it's a niche product I mean
in my personal opinion like this isn't
you know you're not going to see
thousands of these this is something
time uh representative Wendy Thomas
thank you um
you you were just talking about
different kinds of loans and everything
does does the cpce loan um have a set
interest rate or is there a cap on on
the interest or anything like that is
there an advantage to this loan over
other loans other than it goes on the
taxes thank you representative um
they're private loans so the rates are
set by the private Market um mean there
are definite advantages to the borrower
for using a cpce program um you know one
of it one of which is you can get
something financed that's going to make
your
building more stable and profitable in a
way that you can't do sometimes from a
conventional debt um so there's
definitely a borrower benefit um a lot
of times those energy improvements are
are made with owner equity which means
if you talk to the developers you know
who really first raised this issue um
here in the state
that means that Equity is not available
to do the next say housing project or
commercial Redevelopment because it's
all kind of absorbed into one project um
so those are the those are the big ones
followup followup um and is this
anything that can be claimed on taxes or
all as a deduction is that sorry is that
the question representative cor yeah
yeah um I would that is a great question
I am not a tax attorney I would imagine
it is because cpce loans have principal
and interest like any other loan and
interest is generally deductible but
um I think that's I don't know that's a
assume okay seeing no more questions
oops one more question representative
Harrington okay so this is all put out
there for Mak loans easier to get
obviously sometimes in loans there's a
default so the person owning the
property I don't know they die they move
away whatever they they lose their job
they stop making any payments the house
is up for sale it's not moving very good
at all who eats the
cost um in that case it would be the
lender because they've lent the money
and they're at risk um I I would point
out though representative that this is
not eligible for single family homes
this is for commercial properties only I
but your question still stands if
somebody fails and they can't repay
their loans the lenders who lent them
the money are at risk a followup quick
one so there's no liability on the part
of the municipal entity that's
collecting these these fees correct
thank you representative bne has a
question actually Harrington asked and
answered my question so asked and
answered great
we would really like to move along uh
since we've already discussed this bill
at length I think we uh we could do so
comfortably without objection so let's
um thank Mr key Wallace for being here
and let's close the public hearing on
Senate Bill 4 thank you it is
now
247 uh we're going to take a five
minute uh break so that uh we can get
set for an executive session which will
start at
um in 5
yeah feel
did
e
okay please take your seats we're going
session before we begin the executive
session I want to welcome a couple of
guests or or substitutes today
representative Gallagher is here for
representative Kaplan and representative
so with that
introduction I'm going to open a
executive session on House Bill 166 and
I'm going to recognize representative
Harrington for a
motion I move itl on this bill I
recognize representative
PL I second
uh I'm sorry I'm second the motion on
166 okay it's been moved and seconded
that we adopt the motion of itl on House
Bill
166 representative Harrington is
recognized well I think in the testimony
we heard on this it's clear that this is
already going on that all the providers
are making their best effort right now
they're already moving from copper to
fiber and we really don't need a
committee to to look at what's already
occurring uh there's also some technical
mistakes in the bill where it talks
about bringing the Public Utilities
Commission in which has no jurisdiction
over internet and then also Union
Representatives which I have no idea why
they would be want to be brought in as
well but I I just think this bill is
totally unnecessary because the problem
doesn't exist it's taking care of
itself additional comment discussion on
this
bill um representative McGee just to
wage maybe violent agreement
any further discussion
needed seeing none I'd ask the clerk to
call the role on the question of itl on
166 Vice chair
Thomas
yes representative ner yes
representative Harrington yes
representative Bry yes representative
Bernardi yes representative PL yes
representative Summers yes yes
representative Matson yes representative
schneller yes representative McGee yes
representative parshall yes
representative
Gallagher yes representative Thomas
Wendy Thomas yes representative Howard
yes representative rolds yes
representative La relle yes
representative Swanson yes chairman Vose
yes 20
z Mr chairman iest be put on consent EXC
me 18 Z request this representative
Harrington request the bill be put on
consent
calendar without objection this bill
will go on consent representative
Harrington will write the committee
report and I need that by 7 a.m.
please with that we'll close the exec
session on House Bill 16
six next I'll open an exec session on
House Bill 169 and recognize
representative Vice chair Thomas for a
motion thank you Mr chair on HP 169 FN a
motion
itl recognize representative Bernardi
second the
motion moved and seconded that we adopt
the motion of itl on House Bill 169 FN I
recognize Rec uh Vice chair Thomas
thank you Mr chair uh basically uh we
heard testimony that the Pu holds many
hearings without commissions and that
current Commissioners oppose this change
and it really attempts to fix a problem
that really doesn't exist so it's not
needed and for that reason we should itl
it further discussion representative
mgee thank you Mr chairman um I think
the exception that we have I brought you
an amendment that representative Corman
had sent through uh you know digitally
over here to have printed and we brought
it to you for consideration because I
think the only thing he was trying to
clarify in statute is that a majority
means at least two Commissioners and the
point was that uh commission decisions
should be made by more than one
individual and so I think that was the
point of the bill and the amendment
which is uh 2025 2
49h um I handed to you for consideration
anyway for this bill because I think it
clarifies a point that we had been stuck
on when we were in the
committee thank you for that um
explanation so during testimony on that
bill
nobody except the bill sponsor and
the um consumer Advocate asked for these
changes the utilities didn't ask for
these changes U no state agency asked
for these
changes and the Commissioners themselves
and members of their staff indicated
that these changes were not necessary so
given that it doesn't seem to me that
anybody wants these changes except
possibly the consumer Advocate and the
bill sponsor so I think uh this bill
really doesn't have that much support
further discussion representative
Harrington yeah I think uh the bill is
unnecessary because if you read what it
says what it says now before the changes
it says the majority of the commission
shall constitute a quorum well majority
of three is is it two I mean we don't
need to Define that as 2/3 a quorum to
issue orders in any hearing may be held
or conducted by two Commissioners or by
a single commissioner what this means is
that you can have a hearing by with with
either three two or one commissioners
does not mean you can issue orders the
orders must require a quorum and many
times the commission is very busy
someone could be on vacation someone
could be out sick and it's very
difficult to schedule hearings so you
can have a single commissioner there but
be advised every word during that
hearing is transcribed think of uh an
old Perry Mason show for those who old
enough the guy sits there like this and
he does his little thing on the box and
records every word that's uh done and
it's written out and the other train uh
Commissioners who might not be there
there have access to that transcription
so they hear everything that was said at
the hearing and to limit it to two
Commissioners to even constitute a
hearing would bog down the Pu
drastically additional discussion Mr
chair representative McGee yeah I I
don't think it says to constitute a
hearing it says to constitute a quorum
right that's what we're doing is just
defining that a
quorum means majority and a majority of
three Commissioners is two so it's just
defining
says further discussion just I wanted to
respond representative Harrington well
it doesn't specifically but what it
removes is it as the law states now
majority of the commission shall
constitute a quum to issue orders and
any hearing may be held or conducted by
two Commissioners or by a single
commissioner now the new version would
say majority of shall constitute a
quorum and in this chapter majority
means 2/3 of the
commission so it's it's no we didn't
look at the amendment we didn't look at
the amendment but as proposed it it
takes out conducting a hearing by a two
or one or single commissioner which
would imply to me that it's saying you
can no longer do that because otherwise
why take it out so yeah but this we
haven't done anything with this so but
you're going to kill it before you even
okay further discussion representative
PL
uh thank you chair this is to repres
representative Harrington had mentioned
I believe in testimony or back and forth
that others like lawyers also hold
hearings and just this bill limit limits
it to Commissioners only that would
probably tie up hearings if he would
like to elaborate on that
part hearing examiners conduct a lot of
hearings within the Public Utilities
Commission that don't involve
Commissioners at all you're
correct further discussion
representative McGee yeah thank you Mr
chair um I would just like to uh suggest
Which Way um I don't know probably this
way but thank you um i' just like to
suggest that we
maybe
uh vote the itl down so we can hear the
amendment which is designed to address
the issue
I think that we're you know we we
haven't looked at the amendment but the
amendment was really an attempt to save
the bill so that it actually did what
they were looking to
discussion seeing none I'd ask the clerk
to call call the role on the question of
FN Vice chair Thomas
yes representative ner yes
representative Harrington yes
representative Bry yes representative
Bernardi yes representative PL yes
representative Summers yes
representative Matson yes representative
schneller yes representative McGee no
Representative parshall no
representative Gallagher no
representative Thomas Wendy Thomas no
rolds no all right representative L
Rochelle no representative Swanson no
chairman Vos
10-7 by a vote of 10 to7 the motion of
itl on House Bill 169 FN is
adopted representative Thomas will write
the majority report will there be a
Minority
Report yes representative corman's going
to write it representative Corman will
write The Minority
Report
s it's not
here I need that report by 7 A.M
tomorrow
please and with that we'll close the
public the executive session on how
House Bill 169
FN next up let's open an executive
session on House Bill
436 and I recognize representative
schneller for a motion thank you Mr
chairman I recommend that house bill 436
be
ited I recognize representative Matson I
second the motion for itl moved and
seconded that we adopt the motion of itl
for HB 436 representative schneller
uh thank you Mr chair uh this bill may
be interesting may be intriguing uh
alarming on some levels but we had uh no
sponsor no testimony no information no
interest no
discussion uh therefore I recommend that
this bill remain unidentified anom
anomalous and uh henceforth remain the
same therefore I recommend that we itail
this
discussion seeing none I'd ask the clerk
to call the role on the question of itl
436 Vice chair
Thomas
yes representative ner yes
representative Harrington yes
representative Bry yes representative
Bernardi yes representative
PL yes representative Summers yes
representative Matson yes representative
schneller yes representative McGee yes
representative
partial uh sorry uh
yes representative
Gallagher yes representative Thomas
Wendy Thomas yes representative Howard
yes representative La relle yes
representative swan johs son yes
chairman
Vose
yes
170 by a vote of
170 the committee adopts the motion of
itl on House Bill
436 representative schneller will write
the committee report I will get to work
on that immediately Mr chair I need that
by 7 a.m. please Mr chair can we put it
on consent without objection we'll put
this bill on consent
hearing no objection it shall be on
consent so we'll close the public
hearing on House Bill the the executive
session on House Bill
436 now I'll open an executive session
on House Bill 504 relative to State
energy policy and I will make the motion
to adopt house Amendment
2025-the
5H which was just distributed to the
committee and I'll recognize
Thomas
yes I should moved and seconded that we
adopt the amendment
0215 H so let me explain what this
amendment does this amendment modifies
the language in the original bill in the
following ways on line six it adds the
word diverse to the sentence that talks
about affordable reliable and secure
energy resources so that it now reads
affordable reliable diverse and secure
energy
resources on line nine it adds the word
fostering after the word chapter so that
the sentence reads the purpose of this
chapter fostering a range of technology
types on line 10 it adds the following
Choice the next change is on line 14
after the word resources it adds the
F which is the states RPS
on line
15 after the
word well it changes the U that sentence
to read New Hampshire shall allow Market
forces and and the new text is
market-based
mechanisms to drive prudent use of
energy
resources the next change is on line 20
after the word
principles the phrase focusing on Market
transformation is added to the sentence
and on line
21 the end of the sentence is has a new
phrase and consistent with RSA
374f which is the
uh
restructuring statute for the the
electricity market and then the final
change starts on line 23 and ends on
line 24 it adds the phrase public health
and safety to the U sentence that is
essentially paragraph five so those are
the changes that this amendment adds to
changes significantly enhance the
language of the statute or of the
legislation make it clearer and more
understandable and precise with regard
to um what New Hampshire energy policy
should contain by the way this amendment
complet completely
replaces uh section one of the
bill so that is the explanation of the
amendment representative McGee thank you
Mr chair I very much appreciate your
attempts at um modifying language here
based on the input um in the hearing I
think while diverse is um it's it's nice
that that's added on line six the I
think the fuel diversity um efforts made
by the
state
um were more inclusive of energy types
that are not necessarily only reliable
on demand and firm resources there's no
inclusion here of renewable energy
sources which are you know intermittent
but are still adding uh lowering our
demand so they still have a value and
they're no longer listed here as part of
what is intended to be a broad statement
of New Hampshire energy policy so it's
quite a departure and the other issue
that I have although I think the other
word smithing has been you know helpful
uh and and responsive as well it does
right over um 378 37
as a definition of energy policy that I
still believe is is
uh well it's more historically accurate
to how the state was pursuing its energy
policy and it's more uh inclusive of
these ideas that you've got words in
here to allude to um in terms of the way
it's presented uh for public
edification to to state what the state
is actually doing and pursuing this I
think narrows it quite a bit and I think
that may be the intention
uh to narrow what the state's policy is
and its Pursuits are but um fuel
diversity is really the opposite of that
right fuel diversity means that we're
not narrowcasting for particular winners
and losers but that we're allowing fuel
diversity as a way to hedge against cost
spikes and that's I think we share that
goal we're trying to make sure that
people are not
um subject to price spikes because of
the all all the eggs in one basket
scenario that we've been banding about
recently so I will not be voting for
this in its current Incarnation because
I I prefer 378 37 and we've had many
conversations about that section so I'm
still in the camp that wants to preserve
that definition of the New Hampshire
discussion representative
rolds thank you Mr chairman
um uh like representative mige I truly
uh sincerely do appreciate your efforts
your willingness to amend and to offer
um this this amendment in place of your
original bill I think that the changes
you've outlined are definite
improvements however
I uh still will oppose the bill uh for
two major reasons
just
um not it doesn't belong in New
Hampshire's uh energy policy to to claim
a goal of ensuring the state's energy
Independence because New Hampshire is
the
farthest from an potential presently or
potentially energy independent state
that you could have I mean we have no
fossil fuels within our borders and yet
we currently and for a very long time
will uh be substantially reliant on
imported fossil
fuels um and everybody you know accepts
that
um so we we yeah so enough said on that
uh but it leads to my second point which
while you did add the the term diverse
in in the you know line
six
um the other terms you know reliable and
secure uh discount the value they make
no acknowledgment of the value of
intermittent resources which you know as
we've seen from the information
presented to us by the iso New England
the utilities um intermittent resources
provide substantial value yes they're
intermittent but when they are available
and contributing energy to the grid they
enable us to avoid
using uh the the fossil resources we
must import and so they allow those
resources to be preserved for another
time at another day and so I I just
think it's
incomplete to discount them completely
to leave them out so I feel like the
current energy policy is is a good one
and that that's my that's my take on it
thank you further discussion
representative
Barne thank you chairman um so reading
the existing policy the the part that
I've heard so far uh others talking
about is the section of uhow lowest
reasonable cost while providing for the
reliability and diversity of energy
sources I'm I'm having difficulty
reading all of the things that have been
mentioned just from that uh part of the
sentence whereas in the in the new
updated version um I mean it's it's
talking about diversity and it and it
spells out a more
prescriptive uh policy for for the same
thing so I guess I'm not really seeing
where the old policy was more inclusive
different further discussion
representative
Swanson thank you Mr chair I I think
that there are a lot of improvements in
this amendment and uh I'm wondering if
uh I don't know if it's within the scope
I have less experience here but if we
had uh in line nine including but not
limited to On Demand
and Fir resources if we just inserted a
clause but not limited to would that be
more acceptable
discussion all right seeing none I'm
going to ask the clerk to call the role
on the question of the adoption of
amendment
Vice chair
Thomas
yes representative ner yes yes
representative Harrington yes
representative Bry yes representative
Bernardi yes representative PL yes
representative Summers yes
representative Matson yes representative
scheller yes hold on a second please no
talking while we're having a roll call
thank you please continue representative
schneller yes representative McGee no
Representative parshall no
representative Gallagher no
representative Thomas Wendy Thomas
no representative Howard
no Representative
rolds no representative La relle no
yes by a vote of 10 to8 the amendment
021 15h is adopted I now recognize
amendment oh Auto pass as amended on H B
504 recognized representative not I
second the motion moved and seconded
that we adopt the motion of ought to
pass as amended on House Bill 504 as
amended by Amendment
15h any discussion representative
bney pretty much what I said uh while we
talked about the amendment that the the
two the old policy and the I think the
new one is just prescriptive for the for
the old policy But it includes
everything um that was in the old one
just spells it out
more further
discussion representative McGee thank
you Mr chair um actually it I don't
think it does and that's the reason I I
like the very small paragraph that we
have now which I went and looked up it
says the general court declares that it
shall be the energy policy of the state
to meet the energy needs of the citizens
and businesses of the state at the
lowest reasonable cost while providing
for reliability and diversity of energy
resources to maximize the use of
cost-effective Energy Efficiency and
other demand side resources and to
protect the safety and health of the
citizens the physical environment of the
state and the future supplies of
resources with consideration of the
financial stability of the state's
utilities it is a fullsome statement of
all of the stakeholders and all of the
aspects of the energy Market Market
not further further
discussion I recall that the consumer
Advocate once described the existing 378
colon 37 as a contradictory mishmash of
ideas about State energy policy and he
was right and that's why this
amended version of State energy policy
is much clearer and lays out exactly the
principles that state government should
be
following as it tries to secure energy
resources for its
citizens the department of energy
testified on this bill that this
recitation of principles is much easier
to understand and much more implement
able for state government than the
existing state energy
policy so with that I would ask the
clerk to call the role on the question
of ought to pass as amended on House
504 Vice chair Thomas yes representative
ner yes representative Harrington yes
representative Bry yes representative
Bernardi yes representative PL yes
representative Summers yes
representative Matson yes representative
schneller yes representative McGee no
Representative parshall no
representative Galler no representative
Thomas Wendy Thomas no representative
Howard no Representative rolds no
representative La Rochelle no represent
Swanson no chairman V yes
108 I a vote of 10 to 8 the committee
adopts the motion of ought to pass as
amended on House Bill
54 representative bne will write the
majority
report will there be a Minority Report
yes there will it will be representative
Swanson representative Swanson will
write the
Minority Report I need that by 7 am.
tomorrow morning please yes Mr J all
right that
concludes the executive session on House
Bill
504 so now let's open an executive
session on House Bill
dfn and I recognize representative
I recommend ought to
pass recom recognize representative
Summers I second that motion moved and
seconded that we adopt the motion of
ought to pass on House Bill
8 chair recognizes representative
Harrington this is simply a matter of
fairness we've had for for years now the
uh Legacy telephone companies the sort
of if you will left over from Bill uh
from Mount Bell and then independent
companies have been charged a very high
assessment to be regulated by the Pu
except the Pu doesn't regulate them
neither does the department of energy um
they have very little amount of
Regulation that applies to them
practically at all it's almost all gone
away and this would drop their
10% further discussion on House Bill
58-
FN one question uh Mr chairman
yes go ahead representative Harrington
the this is not as amended right so that
was an issue that sounds like my fault I
was supposed to get an amendment to you
which I filed but I haven't gotten a
copy of yet uh on which so yeah it's on
line four where it says 33% is the
chairman pointed out that should have
been dropped down to 10% now I filed
that one with OS but I haven't received
anything so I we forgot about it I
apologize to the committee I
respectfully asked that we put this on
hold until that can be
fixed well thank you for pointing that
out I recommend that we pass this bill
and then ask the Senate to address that
correction that be satisfactory to the
committee normally I don't don't like to
do that I don't like to ask the Senate
to do our work for us but in this
particular case because this kind of got
fell through the TR s and we have a
fairly significant schedule of bills
still waiting our attention I'm going to
suggest that we go ahead and uh adopt
this bill now and point out that error
in the Senate and and ask them to
address it representative
bernardy and ALS another alternative is
for the house to have a floor Amendment
and address it so the house turns over a
good bill to the Senate yeah I like
suggestion i' forgot about that option I
think that we'll do that so
representative Harrington could we
charge you with the responsibility of
making sure that this turns into a house
floor amendment by February 13 right
away thank you okay thank
you any further discussion
needed seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
call the role on the question of the
motion of ought to pass on House Bill
Vice chair Thomas
yes representative not yes
representative Harrington yes
representative Bry yes representative
Bernardi yes representative plog yes
representative Summers yes
representative Manson yes representative
schneller yes representative McGee yes
representative parshall yes
representative Gallagher
yes representative Thomas Wendy Thomas
yes representative Howard yes
representative
rolds yes representative La relle yes
representative Swanson yes chairman
those yes 18 Z by a vote of 18 to Zer we
adopt the motion of a to pass on House
Bill
8 and
no I think we will not put this on
consent because
we we want to want to do a floor
Amendment yeah so and it's an FM
representative Harrington has who will
write the uh committee
report has also uh accepted the
responsibility of crafting and
introducing the floor
amendment when when the time comes Mr
chairman is a question in some advice um
the
um committee report is is fairly simple
to write but should I put in there that
a mistake was made in the Drafting and a
floor Amendment will be coming so that
it's right in there and people see it up
front yes I think that's acceptable by
yes all right so that concludes our work
on House Bill 508 I close that executive
session and now we'll open the executive
session on Senate Bill 4 and I recog I
will make the um motion of ought to pass
on Senate Bill four and recognize
representative
McGee yes I'd second that motion moved
and seconded that we adopt the motion of
ought to pass on Senate Bill
four I will say that this
legislation we think will finally make
the cpay program actually work work and
give people the
opportunity to finance for commercial
buildings long range Energy Efficiency
improvements which
will not only improve the value of the
building long range but also save energy
process the other possibility is that
this bill will actually Aid the effort
to provide more housing
in the state affordable and
otherwise by
allowing buildings to be renovated not
only for cosmetic purposes but also for
Energy Efficiency
purposes will potentially allow more
housing stock to be
developed and provided in our state to
ease our housing shortage so I think
this is a valuable piece of legislation
and I urge the rest of the committee to
adopt it further
discussion representative
Harrington yeah I I'm I thought that we
were told that it was uh commercial only
I didn't know it would app to Residents
and apartments but I thought that's what
the administrator had said but anyways
I'll be voting against this bill because
we haven't had it for it's been sitting
around now for I don't know how many
years 15 years we've done fine without
it it's a new government program that
basically says people aren't willing to
loan this money unless we give them some
kind of a deal from the government to do
it and they say well there's no
financing by the government there's no
liability them what what is the
government providing I don't see that
they're providing anything and I just
don't trust programs like this I think
ultimately it's going to end up costing
the the taxpayers with the local estate
money or the rate payers money but if
there was if there's a project out there
that's economically viable someone's
willing to lend the money if they only
lend the money when there's some kind of
a trick way of Co collecting the
finances when the state gets involved I
I back off went in doubt voted
out okay representative McGee thank you
Mr chairman um my understanding of the
bill is that we're
assisting with capital so that people
can secure financing that makes sense in
terms of the Investments that they're
making and so it's been an idea that's
been around the legislature for a long
time we are the government so we don't
have to talk about them like they're
somebody else but there's no financing
coming from the government there's no
financing coming from the municipalities
this is private dollars and so we heard
all the testimony which I thought was
excellent about um how opening up this
access to Capital is really going to
help people who want to finance these
types of projects and I think it's a
perfectly good use of of our Authority
and also I think it's been vetted
through the leadership on both sides of
the house as well you know the
conversations have been that this is
something that would be a useful thing
for the New Hampshire economy so I don't
think we need to fear that there's going
to be any cost shifting if somebody
takes a private
loan Vice chair Thomas thank you Mr
chair um well I heard testimony that
convinced me that uh the question was
asked if is if there's default if the
owner um passes away uh skattles uh
maybe even if the house burns down who
gets left holding the bill and the
answer was that the lender would be
responsible that the lender would lose
out on money so I believe the state the
municipalities are um are protected so I
will be supporting this
bill representative
Bernardi just to an answer the question
about uh does it apply to housing it it
does not apply to single family homes
but if one is renovating the building to
become an apartment complex or similar
housing
situations uh I think the the monies are
available for that kind of housing
discussion representative bney thank you
Mr chairman um I have a question about
the um if if one of these projects goes
forward um is there any guarantee that
there is efficiency gained and if some
and if you know uh contractor runs up a
huge bill and then the efficiency isn't
isn't gained what happens is is is the
home the property owner now on the hook
for that and then they don't really
benefit from the
upgrade so that was a criticism of the
former um versions of the cpce program
and in some places around the country
where cpce was adopted there were
unscrupulous contractors who were taking
advantage of the program to do shoddy
work and get
repaid based on the guarantees that were
provided by earlier versions of the cpay
program this version does not provide
those kinds of
protections uh if someone hires a an
Energy Efficiency contractor who does
lousy
work the lender is the one who would be
on the hook
for any kind of lawsuit or or inadequacy
that that developed as a result of that
shoty work so it's it's not going to
come back
on the state or the
municipality does that answer your
question does it come back on to the
property
owner by come back on do you mean is it
the property owners responsibility
ultimately yes I mean in in the places
in other places where they have had the
PACE program and then had to cancel it
because of the fraud that you mentioned
um how does this prevent that sort of
fraud from where somebody you know runs
up a Big Bill uh and then doesn't
actually deliver the efficiency that was
promised well since the government is
not directly Evol involved then it would
be the responsibility of the owner of
the building
and the lender who lent the money to
fraud further discussion representative
PL thank you chair um what hasn't
brought up and I'm going to be voting
for the bill is in the back of my head
this is a pro banking bill because we
are eliminating a lot of um
bankruptcies because they will get it
from some owner so the risk is minimal
to a bank to loan this I voted for it
just because this does push forward with
that one minor thing it's helping the
banks in the bankruptcy it'll go forward
that New Hampshire does need a lot of
buildings to be renovated for
efficiency it was
testified I think by James key Wallace
that these loans follow the building not
the owner of the building and that's one
of the advantages of this program
further discussion representative
rolds thank you Mr chairman um yes th
thank you for for that statement that's
correct and that is one of the major
elements of of this Innovative um policy
and I guess uh structure that this that
this law is going to
enable um it's interesting Mr chairman
that your your the amendment to the
energy policy bill and I said I
appreciated it that you included the
term Market
transformation uh this is an example of
that kind of Market transformation the
the policy Innovation that's being put
in
is for the commercial building owners
loan uh to be
uh one attached to the property rather
than uh remain as a as as a personal
liability and number two for the
repayment of that loan to be aligned or
or facilitated by the by the
municipality uh and get the loan is
going to get paid along with the
property taxes so as as the chairman
said introducing the bill it's going
to facilitate
property owners in overcoming the
classic market failure that that
um that bevil's Energy Efficiency which
is the long-term nature of the payback
of the
uh Investments
not not being felt by the building owner
right apartment owners generally don't
upgrade efficiency because they don't
pay the energy bills usually the the um
residents pay the energy bills so
commercial building owners are are you
know tend not to make those those
upgrades they don't bear the the cost it
makes apartment dwellers have high
utility bills which is is a problem in
our state where we have high housing
costs and and affordability so this is
going to address that it's part of
Market transformation and I applaud the
work that's been done on it by as was
mentioned bipartisan
effort further
discussion representative Harrington
I'll make this quick because I don't
want to be overly redundant but it's
what we have is a program here that says
people that would normally be able to
get loans through the market by going
out and saying this is what I want to do
and negotiate with the bank to get it
cannot get the loan because the bank
doesn't think it's a good investment but
somehow getting the government involved
it makes that a good investment I just
that's that's ripe for corruption that's
ripe for uh problems and I can also
assure you of one thing is almost as
sure as I am the Sun is going to come up
tomorrow next year the year after
whenever they'll be back here saying oh
this program is wonderful but it doesn't
help low-income people enough so we have
to subsidize their loans through this
program or it doesn't help people in
some kind of neighborhood or we just got
to expand it and spend a little bit more
money from the government it'll be so
wonderful this is the nose under the
further discussion representative
partial
thank you would you do me a a favor and
yes oh say that
again yes the reign in Spain I'm sorry
was I not coming through you were your
first remarks did not come through I saw
the light on so I thought the microphone
was
on were were you holding the button down
or I I don't no I
wasn't must been I train I heard him but
he wasn't coming through the speaker
yeah yeah I I hear a difference too I I
agree with you there's a difference I
don't know what happened to it but it's
working now okay didn't want listen
further
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role on the question
Vice chair Thomas yes representative ner
yes representative Harrington
no Representative brne
no representative Bernardi
yes representative PL yes representative
Summers
no representative Matson yes
representative schneller yes
representative McGee yes representative
parshall yes representative
Gallagher
yes representative Thomas Wendy Thomas
yes representative Howard yes
representative rolds yes representative
La relle
yes representative
Swanson yes chairman
V
yes 153
by a vote of 16-2
153 15-3
Sorry by a vote of
15-3 the motion of ought to pass is
adopted by the
committee and I will write the
majority opinion will there be a
minority opinion yes I'll write it
representative Harrington will write a
and I need that by 7 a.m. please
tomorrow
morning so with that we'll close the
exec session on Senate Bill
and that concludes our business for
today so I want to thank everybody for
two days of extremely hard
work we got a lot done over the course
of these last two days and we're going
to have to do it again all over again
and next week we'll be meeting on both
Monday and Tuesday of next week and we
will have a full calendar of events
public hearings and executive sessions
Tuesday the house will be in session of
course this Thursday it's our first
business session of the bium so I look
forward to seeing everyone there and
even though the weather forecast for
Thursday is not great uh I was told at
the chair's meeting this morning that
there is no plan to alter the schedule
for
Thursday which just means we are going
to have to ride home in a
snowstorm so we'll see you uh on